the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
you're welcome to look elsewhere but the
best female chess players are at the
Cairns Cup in St Louis with the leader
on a buy Contender saw a shiny
opportunity to gain ground but were met
with ferocious opposition smooth sailing
for Alexandra castenia corrupted into
disaster as she blew a clear lead from
the opening cratering her place in the
standings Bella cotanesh villey awakened
from her extended rest day to continue
her fiery Rampage destroying Elizabeth
Pates on her way to the top satonsky's
out front but if Bella stays on course
there's no telling how far she'll go day
eight of exciting chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone it's a gorgeous day here
in San Luis I'm standing in front of the
world's largest chess piece in front of
the world just Hall of Fame and I cannot
wait for around eight to start let's go
to the studio and get the action started
welcome to Saint Louis the home of Chess
in America and the third edition of the
Karens cup one of the richest women's
tournaments in chess we come to you live
from the San Luis chess club
hello and welcome everyone thank you so
much for joining us I'm International
Master nazify kids and I'm here with
Grandmaster yesterawan Nasi as always a
pleasure to be with you the number of
decisive games continues to impress
yesterday against 75 I mean what is
going on hello everyone Welcome to our
show thank you for sharing your day with
us decisive Games Galore and it
continues to be that way but so far it's
been the Anna zatonski show will it
continue well let's take a look at the
standings and find out let's take a look
we have in the clear first tournament
leader Anna zatoski with four and a half
points out of six in the clear second
following closely Bella hotanashrilly
with four points out of six and as you
see Elizabeth Hayes has played seven
games and so is insaya also played seven
games they're going to be getting a buy
why are they getting a buy because our
defending Champion canero with Rufus
from the tournament due to illness so
each round a player is getting to buy it
and it impacts the standings as you see
and tell us about the format uh let's
see right we have a nine player round
dropping tournament with no draw first
and the type control is 90 minutes for
first 40 moves 30 minutes rest of the
game and 30 second increment for move
one and the schedule is getting more
narrow we have two days left the players
will play round eight today and the
final round tomorrow however if players
are tied at the end of the tournament
we'll have a playoff day on Tuesday June
13th if necessary might be necessary
very fortunate to have in studio
almerica bonjour Almera and tell us
about the possibilities of who can win
the event
our tournament leader Anna zatonski had
such an impressive tournament so far she
didn't lose this single game so let's
play our favorite game what if
loses and Irina Crush draws Anna zato
can win the tournament on the spot she
can clinch the victory today so let's
have a look at our key pairing today
another tonskeer is playing against
jeans abdomalik
is a tough opponent to beat especially
with the white pieces but please have a
look at their head-to-head score they
played only two games one classical and
one rapid game and Anna lost both of
them so I think that the stakes are so
high now that Anna will play even more
cautiously with white pieces and I think
she might be happy with the draw
especially that it will bring her even
closer to the GM Norm what do you think
guys absolutely thank you absolutely
Anna does need a 50 out of the last two
games two draws one win today clinches
the GM Norm but uh do the honors lay the
table for audience tell us tell them
what they can expect in terms of the
penultimate round pairings let's take a
look at today's pairings we have
Alexander cost in your playing Bella
Hoten is really
against Irina crush and our tournament
leader anasutowski will be facing John
Saya Abdul Malik absolutely and there's
the tournament by Elizabeth Pates for
round eight uh they've been fighting
hard and fighting for lots and lots of
money the prize fund for this 2023
Cairns cup yes there's total
a place winner is going to win forty
five thousand dollars second place
thirty five thousand third twenty five
thousand and a very nice Payday for
everybody all the way to the 10th and
final uh prize of six thousand and we
saw there in the Hall of Fame where
they're playing right across the street
from us here at the St Louis chess club
the rounds eight is coming up uh empty
tables at the moment I guess the players
are getting wanded and all eyes on
amazonski what a
did you see this coming she came in as
the lowest rated player in the field I
don't think anyone saw it coming she was
definitely the underdog coming into the
tournament exactly but at the same time
we know how strong Anna is her pick
rating was 25.37 so of course she is
capable of beating any of these players
right and she's showing that she's in
great form in this tournament no
question about it as as you say
undefeated performance and Anna has the
problem I have seen in her game in the
last few years is her inconsistency
capable of playing really really good
chess on any given day she's also given
away lots of points but this tournament
she's put it all together and she's
having well I want to say a career
performance Amira yes and I really think
that honest style fits a super
tournaments more because Harry Potter is
classic and very solid so when she needs
to take a lot of risks risks and beat
maybe a lower rated opponent then it can
backfire but here as an underdog of the
tournament at the beginning of the event
she psychologically feels uh quite free
I think so she she just can play a good
game every day absolutely and also the
bell of the ball
as a Bella comes in on a win streak
Thorn row she's going up against former
world champion Alexander kostenyuk I
don't know exactly how these two players
match up but this lady
Bella is the one putting the pressure on
Anna zatanski and they're saying to uh
Alexander please please stop stop her
and in the head to head they've had 11
games played and Alexander has five wins
two losses and four draws Alexandra
playing white and day and again Anna's
saying well somebody please stop Bella
four on a on a win streak or win win
streak and there's Alexandra well
Alexandra is a very tough opponent for
anyone but I think that the tournament
Dynamics favors Bella slightly because
we know that Alexandria is playing
uncompromised in chess so she will try
to win with white and Bella just won
four games in a row right well for me I
if I'm on a streak I like to push it and
like let's go I mean when else am I
going to win five in a row you know
let's do it if you were in honest
situation would you be playing for a win
today since she has the white pieces
yeah that's the tough one it's not like
I would be playing for a win as much as
I'm playing for an advantage I just want
to come out of the opening with an edge
and to feel myself am I feeling good do
I want to press my advantage but yes
when I'm white I'm of the opinion that I
should be playing for an advantage if I
come to the game Thinking winner winner
I'll die you know that's not the
attitude I want that usually happens in
the last round if you absolutely need a
win absolutely but Anna only needs 50
out of this last two games right it's
been a tumultuous tournament for our
eight-time U.S Champion Arena Crush she
started really well with two wins out of
the first three games then she had two
losses
came back yesterday with a win and still
in contention if her opponent's Anna and
Bella were to both lose that would open
up a possibility for her today because
Irina is playing online
matchup that somebody a Hollywood script
writer uh you know had written that into
the contract that it would have to be a
last round exciting game and we have a a
new lady with the bell and actually I'm
so happy if we will keep the Intrigue in
this tournament I really want to see
Irina versus Anna tomorrow
so this is a chess player Anna from uh
Webster Groves Webster University
thank you for doing the honors of me and
we are underway everybody this is the
penultimate round what I like to call
the championship rounds because it's in
these rounds and even if you're having a
terrible tournament like a really bad
tournament if you can put together two
wins at the very end of the tournament
you kind of walk away with good memories
right as they say all's well that ends
well exactly and for zinsaya she's just
had a very bad event no ifs ands or buts
about it but if she can play the role of
spoiler today and it's worth mentioning
today is actually her last game of the
tournament because tomorrow he she has a
buy exactly so it's all her bust yes
what I wanted to mention is that they
had such different trajectories in this
tournament Anna is leading the event and
Josiah no one they really expected that
she is on the last place absolutely
absolutely I I kind of felt that she
would come in uh as uh as kind of a
pre-term and Underdog favor but there uh
what Amira showed us earlier in the show
the head
so she doesn't
have lost two games against
from last year from last year but today
is a very different situation exactly
but it you know you you still remember
those losses that's the point so it's
not like she snake bitten or anything
like that but she doesn't want to do
anything that could spoil a great result
and again
two draws clinch is a grand master
result as it does a victory by Anna
today Knight C3 I'm expecting Anna to
play the Queen C2 classical nimso Indian
something she said I guess I think she's
always played E3 also E3 yep oh no that
that's wrong she played it through once
couldn't sit to rest all the time right
Queen C2 A variation I've always favored
Gary Kasparov picked up the classical
Queen C2 and just infused it with a lot
of new ideas and sort of like these
age-old openings are good friends that
you can come back to Queen C2 you just
to prevent the doubling of the pawns on
the queen side play a2a3 grab the two
Bishops and hope it brings you success
in the later middle games let's just uh
just take a lot of theory exactly in
this position uh let's go around the
horn and Almera I see you have another
game looks like an open rui uh in front
of you exactly because this one is also
of a crucial importance for our
standings today Alexandra questionnaire
is playing with the white pieces that's
an open Spanish and I was just waiting
for
here this one of the critical positions
so which line will Alexander choose so
Knight bg2 C3 was another possibilities
a lot of games have been played in this
line and Fabiano caruana has won well a
few years ago against
Sergey Korea but this is this position
is highly theoretical uh there's still a
lot of possibilities so we need to wait
for a few moves
I I remember
vishi Anand versus Gary kaspara for Gary
prepared a rook sacrifices like you say
very very heavy uh theoretical uh play
in that position so that's take a look
at the gunai and Irene's happening yes
so Arena when she was up against
Alexandra she wanted to play her browser
Rouser I always it's funny Rouser I've
always associated with Bishop G5 and I
always Associated this as the classical
Sicilian you know you the Four Knights
are out on on the board but the Rouser I
always Associated when white initiated
the Rouser with Bishop G5 classical
Sicilian but with Bishop C4 Bobby
Fischer favorite just uh preparing to
put the bishop back on the B3 Square so
that if you should ever cast along you
got an extra guy over there E7 E6 Bishop
E3 A7 A6 Queen E2 and white is preparing
to Castle long and I'm going to say that
for arena she really enjoys
these Sicilian positions they offer
great counter-attacking uh
play and really suits her style yeah and
well it's also like she's having a
really nice tournament too with black
you might think okay I'll play it a
little defensively minded no no no no no
no uh she's saying let's play and uh all
results possible three results also
Queen C7 so if you have this position or
you're castling long or you cancel that
definitely long but aren't you it was a
time actually so I'm a defer player but
I start to play E4 as well yeah but
especially played E4 against players who
played C5
just so I could cast along
and have these bevel uh Edge positions
so castles long invites Bishop E7 and
Castle short and then everybody's
favorite you know you play for Attack on
the king side with G4 I'll play for an
attack on the queen side with B5 and let
the chips fall where they make actually
a little surprise already instead of
long Castle
in this specific yeah that's it that's a
a strange move in this specific position
because Knight takes C6
you know if you wanted to play Knight
take C6 you might have done that a move
ago just to deny
the option yeah just I I'm ready to get
play B take C6 right normally but Queen
takes C6 I do pick up a Tempo so at
least I I would consider the move uh
this seems like a rare guest uh in this
position uh Almera Knight takes C6 has
that become topical
well I still have two games in this
position but one of them was played
recently by a young Serbian Grandmaster
vilimir ivich so after Knight C6 let me
check like what was in the game no it
was in the game
BTE xc6 was played because Queen C6
seems a bit artificial here to me so G4
a very interesting move Bishop B7 can be
played but black played H5 in this game
so what is White's idea is to play G5
you can play Knight G4 hero Knight D7 uh
black chose Knight G4 in this game as
you can see the
the evaluation of the computer is going
up all the time so here I think what is
important is not to give this bishop so
you will have to make this move Bishop
D2 and I just ask myself a question what
will happen if I will play Queen B6 I
will just check it a little bit so I do
not allow you to Castle but simply F4
okay with the yes a devastating
initiative so
um black played in this game night E5
then then Bishop B3 and F4 follows is
coming yes it's coming so even if you
play A5 here with the idea of playing uh
Bishop B6 F4 and White's position is
much much better here exactly well the
move H5 is certainly a provocative move
uh sorry you said Knight takes C6 Queen
takes C6 is a little artificial uh share
share with our viewers why you felt that
to be the case because to my mind Queen
takes C6 is kind of viable I want to put
the pressure on the E4 Pawn right away
yes I was looking at it from the Paulson
perspective of course this is a
different opening so let's try because
you want to bring this phone and to play
D5 actually and then I realized when we
were analyzing the position that you
almost never have the possibility of
playing D5 in this position and that
might be actually the huge problem so
what happens after Queen C6 in the game
we had Bishop D3 then
um one of those seven Bishop D7 or
Bishop B7 so this is already an all so
let's say what happens what should we do
Castle long here okay Castle short
Castle short and maybe G4 right as in
the game we can try G4 okay I have a few
games now by transposition so right F4
Bishop G5 but what if G4
then simply B5 exactly but I love these
positions because you know it's uh uh
everybody's on a tightrope you know you
can you can fall off with just a any
single move yeah so if age four here
then after before black was already
better right yes because your knight has
to go to B1 and then massive passively
placed it's a very passive push through
indeed so maybe this is a very
interesting concentration yes sir well
you may stay
Thank you very much Bishop D3 was a
little bit of a surprise for me I I kind
of expected you even though you didn't
like it to play F3 I have three I just
uh okay F3 Bishop E7 Bishop B3 castles
castles long but I wanted to check
something can you actually take this
pound for example if I play Bishop B3
can you take the pawn on e4 well I would
ask that question Bishop A4 B5 V5 Knight
B5
uh I gotta Play Bishop D7
7th so Knight C3 here it's ah Knight
takes C3 Bishop Bishop C6 yes
so maybe that was not even a threat in
that position yes it's a lovely
variation but
um that's something that you have to
consider as well so maybe bishop B3 is
possible and then long castle Yeah okay
let's go to the game of Alexandria and
checked one game oh pardon me harika
against Nana they're still very early in
the opening we have a Catalan
yeah a Catalan slav right because it's
like G3 takes open Catalan but then with
the move C7 C6
uh intimating rather
forcefully I might play the move B5 and
retain the pawn on a c four uh A4
before is uh most common move I I
believe right but can also plays C5 in
this position having having provoked yes
C6 uh move C5 yeah and black is playing
as if it's Queen's Gambit accepted
exactly and sometimes the move A4 is
actually you know misplaced because you
you do like these ideas of 95 and queen
A4 check I wanted to go to Alexandra
let's just uh jump in again this was the
open uh rui uh we left it just to these
the spartanite BT D2 Bishop E7 uh again
the theory is so so deep Bishop C5 tons
and tons of game C3 castles Bishop C2 C5
apartment F5 Knight B3 this is I I've
been seeing this oh yeah and I've been
seeing this variation getting a workout
lots and lots of games from this moment
I think the main move here is F3 yeah
exactly 95 and then I think A4 is the
most common move exactly and
if we check players time they also of
course know this opening Bella has hour
32 Alexandra Hour 30. exactly
um
Almera I wanted to ask is the open rui
a variation that Bella plays often in
other words this is in her repertoire
because these positions are very awkward
to play no
yes and they rely mostly on your uh well
positional understanding because it's
almost like a conceptual battle exactly
so black claims that uh
well the C5 Pawn is what can be easily
easily stopped of course the queen is
not the best
blockade yes so she I think she likes to
put Bishop F4 is pretty new
Bishop F4 that is definitely off the
Beaten Track she played it really fast
so she has this she has well that was
why I was really asking the question
about Bella in other words is Alexandra
you know like saying oh I know my
opponent is going to play this defense
like your Karo Khan for example so this
move Bishop F4 very uncommon move tell
me about this one
yes it's a very rare move yes what I
wanted to tell is of course that if you
manage to put the Knight on E6 of course
this will be an ideal position uh for
black but for the moment the Knight is
going to F7 in this position so let's
have a look
um
last games played in 2022 but I don't
have the top players here let me check
just one second this is not the top line
of the computer so quite a clever
preparation by Alexander I think so what
can you suggest here Queen C6
I want to I want to put the Knight on E6
as you said that's the ideal Square so
vacate it oh no like well I'm dazzled
because now the computers just because
this is one of the main ideas in this
position so you take on G5 you take on
G5 and you play F4 but now that you've
played Queen C6 the computer takes on G5
so what is the best question it should
be seven it's a natural square and then
maybe Queen F3
the the thing is that you always have
this very dangerous plan in this
position white always wants to play G4
so how should black proceed here maybe
Rook 88 a very human move for me let's
say Rook D1 we improve our rook and so
let's say after Rook D1 we are
in uncharted waters here well I think
they're Strangers Like The Queen Is On
C6 now I want to go back to East exactly
it's misplaced at E6 okay I'll go back
with the queen so maybe that's why the
computer actually suggests here as I
said that you have no time to put your
knight on um E6 so maybe you should go
Knight F7 okay you should not allow this
trade and well you're you're not really
going to take only five because then the
position is going to be completely open
uh but what to do here rookie one no
okay it seems very natural to me
and okay another interesting move I I
would play Rook d8 here but
it's a very interesting maneuver so he
actually brings the Knight to C6 here
or it I mean I know it's a lot of Tempe
but maybe he now wants to play Queen C6
and Knight E6 that's the ideal block
hating Square for the night but just not
to allow the bishop G5 what you showed
up now yes let's let's see how should
white continue because the computer
always hesitates here of course he gives
a slight Advantage for white almost all
the time but then they well he changes
his plan so should he play B4 A4 at some
point so I think you you adapt to the
situation right now the situation has
changed for example he played Bishop
before Queen C6 then you take on G5 then
if the Knight of 47 you play A4 if the
Knight is somewhere else then you play
B4 but I'm a bit puzzled by this idea
let's say B4 C takes B4 ah and then
Bishop B3 okay that's uh that's an
excellent yes right that's an excellent
trick trick so after B4 are you forcing
black to play C4 here most probably and
now you can play A4
I'm liking white in this case I I didn't
like the move C4 so much maybe Queen C6
and that exact moment
again I I'm I have I'm a one-trick pony
I'm trying to put the pony on the E6 and
what if I'd say can then play Bishop B3
okay let's check yes you will take with
it of course I check let's say Bishop C5
yeah King H1 yeah as you're reaching for
your Bishop you're going out it's check
and Knight E6 and then I I hopefully I'm
in time to play Rook d8 and defend the
d-pawn yeah should we no I don't want to
exchange the Bishops here yes Bishop
Jitsu yes but on the other hand are you
going to open the position you're not
going to play D4 you're not going to
play F4 so your pieces are well very
harmoniously placed as it is so right
you will have to come up with a more
active plan maybe which is involving the
C file I I find this to be a fascinating
battle as both players have imbalances
that they can proudly point at and say
you know like I've got I've got an edge
here you've got an edge there White's
pawns are split on the queen side you've
got she's got the two Bishops let's just
jump to Anna's game once again because
let's see what developments have taken
place here when we left it we saw the
move Queen C2 Castles by Jean Saya
a2a3 Bishop takes Queen takes you see
how I did that I just said jensaya like
it was the most natural thing in the
world and it only took me eight rounds
to get the courage to try to pronounce
the names
a2a3 Bishop so I've got the two Bishops
all very standard stuff until I see the
move C7 C5 uh Bishop H7 H6 Bishop B7 D5
but the move C5 actually takes me back
to Old Days uh I feel like that's uh
that's in the dusty part of the
repertoire do you take C probably is
that no yeah D takes c b takes C
and I for for me if I'm in honest shoes
I'm feeling very very happy because I'm
feeling like Bishop takes F6 you're not
going to want to play G takes F6 you're
going to want to take the Queens off the
board and I'm not going to lose that
ending I I kind of feel like I I have a
bit of an edge maybe not that it doesn't
need to take on episode right away no
but it's like one of those things that
you kind of say that option yeah yeah
I'm playing for an advantage or a slight
Advantage with the white pieces so I
think most important thing for Anna is
to not take big risks in the last round
so the position we're just talking about
after Bishop F6 why it has no risks
whatsoever this one takes takes I seem
to feel really include E3 okay and on
the next move maybe it should be seven
Knight F3 so it's at a certain point I
have to declare myself right am I going
to be playing D5 or am I going to play
D6 or Knight C6
um
yeah well I mean
the one thing no the one thing no 94 in
this case this is just a pawn uh
yes I could just take this ball yeah
that's just that's a just a good point
so I don't have to worry about 94.
um bail is out of this one uh Almera uh
this opening that zansaya has chosen
against
um
Anna it feels like
Anna's got a very nice position after he
takes takes and we're looking at both E3
and Knight F3 what is uh
what what's attractive in this position
for black what is black trying to do
actually I played the this position a
few times it and it might look innocuous
but this is uh this is the point let's
say if you play E3 then Black Goes D6
and what is it it doesn't matter really
if you play your well Bishop D3 let's
say Knight D7 then we developed the
knights only two when F3 once again it's
the matter of taste but what black wants
to achieve let's say you can Castle
and then actually here
you don't have a very comfortable way of
attacking the pawn on D6 and even though
let's say you will play Bishop Bishop I
will play A5 Bishop C2 you will double
your Rooks and even if you play F4 then
this move is actually very strong
because you are not afraid to give away
the D5 Square because the Knight does
never go in there and you can even
create an attack uh well uh on the white
Kings so you have to be very careful
because you cannot equalize comfortably
here because
of the structure in the center those
bounds are very mobile
all right so that's like there is no
easy way if Anna would want to make a
draw here there is no easy way to make
it here
okay so you will have to maneuver your
way in this game and pay attention like
uh to every move
interesting because I kind of saw it as
Black's Center is a little bit stuck I
want to say uh D6 and E5 but okay two
Bishops we'll keep an eye on that one I
wanted to turn our attention to Arena
Crush uh physician because she did with
the queen yeah she said hey that is
actually a very nice Tempo Queen takes
C6 you're going to pay attention to E4
maybe I I don't threaten to do it
immediately but at certain moment you
might be forced to play F3 Bishop to D3
kind of what we were looking at Bishop
E7 castles and I'm expecting castles and
this double-edged variation G4 B5 G5
Knight D7 and Away the players would go
uh great stuff and for Arenas
I think that arena is going to be happy
because basically she's played this her
whole career these types of open
Sicilians she feels very comfortable in
them so yes yes I just have a small
suggestion in this position because if
Arena castles I think the most precise
move in this position would be F4 F4
because F4 does not allow B5
so let's say if you play B5 in this
position then I strike immediately in
the center I will play E5 and then here
you're facing uh well a difficult choice
because let's say if you take only five
you define
um the structure the structure is 95 and
maybe 95 here e takes D5 because you
cannot take on D5 of course with the
queen because of this terrible Bishop H7
right a very
um standard tactical motive here but
then after Knight D5 Knight D5 it takes
D5 these are not really the pounds that
you want to have here so the bishop is
looking at the black skin so I think
that white species are way active Here
and Now B5 is looking into the void if I
might say there is no longer the night
on C3 and what else can you do probably
I can even play one more prophylactic
move King B1 and then launch launch an
attack H4 H5 H6 bring my Rook so maybe
slightly better for white but much
easier to play for White Once Again
intriguing because again these are the
battles that I love to play I like your
F4 because of what you were saying about
B5 but even to go down the whole
Primrose pathway you've suggested with
Knight takes D5 I'm still not convinced
that both players aren't going to make
efforts at mauling one another's Kings
because they're you know I agree H4 h5h6
let's go but these Bishops are kind of
solid these Bishops are very solid but
I'm looking at B3 and doubtlessly you'll
be playing for G4 G5 fun stuff a little
bit behind the G Pawn for me white seems
a little bit slower a little bit slower
yeah well the G4 G5 question in that
position we just had yeah the black
pawns were much faster maybe on the
queen side
and let's just remind our viewers what a
roller coaster ride Arena has had as we
opened our show telling she was in first
place after three rounds she started
with two and a half out of three if she
was leading the tournament but then came
three difficult rounds she lost two and
Drew one right and she came back
yesterday with a win and she's looking
to finish one yeah
harika yesterday was a good game round
two became a buy she actually did of
course play against canero when she was
in the tournament and those beings were
count for rating purposes it's just that
homepie's event was canceled if you will
and for two of the players Nana and
Alexandra they were let's say
disappointed that their points got taken
away uh by the way uh the move F F4
which I think is a really outstanding
move uh to my mind when I see the movie
I really want to play B5 and I really
want to be able to kick the Knight if B5
does get answered by E5 and that whole
variation we just saw I understand that
you as the player with the white pieces
want to start a pawn storm one of the
best if not the best ways of meeting a
pawn star is to get out of the way if
you see that G4 and G5 are going to come
with the tempo get your pieces out of
the way so they don't come with them 97
is a move I kind of need it's a good
prophylaxis move something we would have
to make anyways exactly it's a move I'd
like to make anyways and maybe on a very
very good day A Sneak my Bishop to F6
and use the square so F4 Knight D7 and
you also still want to play B5 now
precisely that's exactly what I'm trying
to do is play B5 B4 and keep the pieces
on the board and make the suggestion
that hey I've got a nasty attack uh one
of the things uh I think a lot of people
who play the Black side of the Sicilian
will recognize and be aware of is you've
always got to look out for these uh
little moves of Knight D5 so something
like Bishop D4 yeah you you want to play
B5 and you could see a move like Knight
D5 suddenly show up on your doorstep
with or without B4 by the way and it's a
little bit of a shock and these moves
are playable so very often if you look
at the top Grandmaster games and you'll
see
um Gary Kasparov especially he sneaks in
that move rookie eight you know like on
so many
but also opens up the f8 square for the
bishop in order to defend G7 if
necessary exactly so these uh these
um open Sicilian positions they have
their own
eye delicate uh moments patterns of
moves that you see in different types of
Sicilians with similar ideas exactly
Almera uh over to you and
oh we have a I wanted to finish here
with the analysis of this position
you're absolutely right Knight D7 is a
very nice move in this position Bishop
D4 is following one game that they still
have in the database and after Rook E8 I
think that white has a big Advantage
after E5 E5 yes because if you take then
F takes I open the f file and your Rook
is no longer on the fade so as you can
see is uh computer loves it loves it and
yeah everything is open here so I'm not
even sure who is defending the Monarch
here so we'll have to bring your knight
to a fade but this position is really
dangerous so you have to be careful in
your approach
very good uh thank you for that by the
way I didn't realize that E5 could
really put the kibosh on those attacks I
wanted to say that on as the sun that's
why we have Almira and Oracle exactly uh
to help us and keep us on our toes uh
this looks like a move that I would play
actually I love these uh
um provocative moves I want to put it
like this this move Knight H3 the idea
provoking it's Provo well what I want is
I want to win your pawn and it
it kind of provokes you to play H6
because I don't think you want to see
the night land on H5 like if you if you
played something like very slowly Bishop
B Sava and D6 Knight H5 Knight D7 you
may not like this uh this may not uh be
what you can notice night H5 I thought
Knight was coming to F4 right just to
deal with the center maybe against D5
but right just sneaky little idea yeah
don't tell anybody about it right I mean
and of course if you uh again Knight H5
but if not another sneaky idea of
putting the Knight there is normally
speaking you defend the pawn whenever it
gets attacked with a move like King G7
no King G7 in in in this case because uh
there's only six game games played
previously yes sir can you get Robert
hubner Dr Robert Huebner on the line yes
yes because this was his invention yes
this was his idea this is such a rare
and I think a well forgotten line
because I think that
um after a few years it was considered
that black is doing fine here so but uh
so Knight H3 and then well I have a few
recent games here uh should you play H6
immediately here or Knight C6 this is
quite a dilemma so let's see what
happens after H6 and you can see there's
not many they not many games in the
database so queen of six of course
because uh yes sir pointed out that this
is not your opening
conception Concepts where the Knight is
going to age five but queen of six is a
very good move in this position because
you are actually happy to exchange the
Queen the Queens in this position
different way because of the power non
B2 so if you don't Castle long this
might as well be a very important Target
right backward Pawn yes so Knight F4 and
here like
black is simply ignores the threat of
Knight H5 plays Knight C6 or Bishop B7
maybe I don't know what is the best
let's try Bishop B7 and
I know yes sir that you want to know
what is going on here but I think the
computer evaluates this position is well
slightly better for black or equal
because he doesn't know how you're going
to develop right here yes so let's uh I
don't know Rook d8 because he wants to
play D5 then Knight F6 King f8 it would
be interesting to continue this
variation can you Castle along here once
again this this is not the move which is
even proposed by the computer but I
think what he States here is King E7
then Knight H5 Knight G4 where they want
to put it yeah I spent a lot of time
winning a double Pawn
and here's simply Knight C6 and well as
you can see the valuation yourself the
dynamical play gives black sufficient
compensation here exactly and I do
believe by the way as you were speaking
uh Josiah did play the move H7 H6 it's
on the board and well Anna's played
pretty briskly I want to say for her
not bad not bad at all age seven he's
gonna take on F6 as well exactly one
thing I wanted to ask you Almira is when
I'm looking at the position this ending
if you will
if I do have a fear I I don't know if
that's the correct word but if I'm
worried that this Pawn on B2 might
become backward after Knight C6 A5 and
Rook B8 I've got a a problem child this
Pawn on V2 a sorrow child
yeah oh the benoni child okay uh b2b4
just get really get rid of my potential
weakness has that been essayed but after
before I will not take I think very
often uh black simply leaves the pound
on C5 and a lot of nimsa structures I
want to create weaknesses everywhere a
lot of violence of maybe Knight C6 if
you play B5 right there goes the problem
child it's no longer backward so Knight
D5 or maybe not 95 here I think 95 years
is the most interesting move you're also
threatening uh well the bound on C4 of
course but after E3 yes maybe you can
play A6 here and challenge wow this
immediately if but somehow it feels like
we just went from a strategic struggle
to a sharp struggle like now things are
you know Tempo dependent ASAP
786-8384 you know if you undermine my
part my passer I'll be worse right if
they keep it and I could be better and I
think our Queen side pawns are doing
great but we're still so behind in
development that that will show itself
right but okay uh next turn night of
through night of well okay it could
become a sharp game after Bishop F6 and
B4 or strategic game please one last
word about these positions and it's not
so much about the variations it's just
in the lines is that from a personal
experience I know how difficult it is to
evaluate those positions I really have
no clue what the assessment will be on
the next move from a human perspective
and the computer even confirms it now
like we have this incredible Quantum
analysis but uh when you're playing the
game uh this is not obvious at all so
Anna might as well feel that this is
close to equal or she's winning the
pound and she will tell herself I cannot
be worse with the pound up and I already
traded the Queens but uh this might be
as well
[Music]
it could be an illusion yes right uh
turning our attention to Alexandra and
Bella's game I think the move Bella
chose after Bishop F4 perfectly
reasonable move in my estimate so let's
Rook on A8 to d8 and in a lot of cases
A2 a4s like sometimes a problem that the
Rooks can get traded and maybe the
f-pawn is weak when The Rook is suddenly
called to duty Rook f8 takes a this move
I like because it basically Intimates
hey wait a minute I'm the one with the
extra Center pawn and I want to go D5 D4
and blast open the position and if I do
that oftentimes
the king can be vulnerable on this
diagonal like for example just to
illustrate make a very bad illustration
is like oops and I'm going to play for
D4 so I I think a prophylactic move was
King H1 which was played and again it
seems to me that Alexandra is in her
preparation yeah because she's playing
all of these most difficult moves Bishop
F4 King H1 pretty it's just the last
hour 29 minutes so yeah I think that's
in this position before I think that's
safe to say and as always during these
moments we want to invite you our
audience to join us join the discussion
stomp our panel with any queries
questions you might have about the
players or even the history of Chess how
can they do that how can they join the
conversation
they can reach us using Karen Scotland
across the all social media you can join
us at the Saint Louis chess club
channels and uh send us your questions
and comments and our social media
manager Sabina feusser will be happy to
give us your questions Sabina has been
having a lot of fun she's been raiding
US during our breaks and getting us to
do video clips for her behind the scenes
and is she even
uh I got Tom our producer she's very
good at her job no uh Tom's making a
cameo apparent so
um you know with Cheetos too by the way
so uh yeah check out the final product I
know she's been working on it so hard
um King H1 and let's go again uh to uh
irina's game I was going to say nana we
haven't so Nana said players are playing
quite slowly exactly in the opening a2a4
B7 B5 hey I want to keep the pawn not a
thought about B5 move for 25 minutes
25 minutes okay so standard stuff is
season before and say five I shot the
two main moves yes and
no I'm curious what she she was
wrestling with this question can I keep
the plot go ahead please uh since I play
the cattle and I'm used to seeing this
but you know 95 looks pretty good with
or with with or without trading on B5
not trading now you want to keep the
tension okay so 95 in the words of
Walter Sean Brown immediately
immediately night okay you're hitting
the pawn yes okay
um
I will check you
okay I was not expecting
that I didn't so Bishop D2 I was wrong
Knight C3 okay and Knight D5 okay
so I have to block the attack that you
were setting up with your Bishop on G2
as well as your knight hitting C6 so I
blocked the attack potentially well I
don't know if I'm threatening to capture
twice on C3 but this was the idea behind
Bishop before a takes B okay now you
want to take
uh now you're making me think you know
because I mean you know I can resist
anything except Temptation you know
that's my problem right Knight takes
even okay okay you convinced me I
shouldn't take then Castle just Castle
okay I was bluffing I actually don't
know
well you blocked me uh you've left me
pretty good takes takes I'm not gonna
take on C3 and taking on D4 but Bishop
B7 are we it doesn't look like we're in
theoretical territory uh we're on our
own I have Bishop A3 ideas just to deal
in this Castle yes but maybe at some
point I shouldn't defend that pawn on C3
I might take it one one of these days
absolutely uh I feel that this is
actually a pretty darn sharp position
and it's something you don't want to get
yourself into without preparation right
so the fact that nanative 25 minutes to
play B5 uh bring us up to date on this
uh dispute that is going on here Almera
B5 good or bad well indeed it's a highly
theoretical dispute but uh as uh Nana
State showed us she is willing to go all
in in her game so it's a quite
well it's a dubious consonation I would
qualify is it such so after B5 you can
play Knight E5
um one of the top games was played
between anishkiri and Alexander
morosevic you can even take on B5 first
and then play Knight E5 of course black
is not losing because they always have
this very important defensive resource
Knight D5 because otherwise of course
The Rook is going to be lost but then
probably Knight C3 right in this
position so Bishop before Castle
funnily enough this is almost the
position we achieve yes so this is
something very possible I like the
engines what happens they're good you
should take another pound but so after
Queen C2 I think uh well you've had it
all and after Knight D5 I may be Bishop
A3 you know so I do not allow you to
Castle and with a long-term initiative
here I think so you will have to deal
with a lot of problems but I feel that
maybe Knight E5 here is more precise
yes keeping the tension so Knight E5
that's how the games went so Knight D5
and then I even have a game played by a
vessel evanchook so vital to create this
love but all those games are not very
recent so uh I think that the computers
are much more powerful of course right
now and as you can see the evaluation is
uh
once again given the advantage to White
and you can play castle here or you can
enter the the line that you've analyzed
once again so
um
the Nana
will have to find the continuation after
95 here but Knight D5
is probably the only move here can you
give check first what do you think
does it change something
I think I was actually giving you were
given the check first but after
9395 it was the kind of a trance it's
their position it's the repetition of
the repetition so I think you you don't
have to play Bishop D2 here yes I think
so we'll have to wait a little bit but
actually I had one uh very important
moment sure in the game between
Alexandra castino and Bella Hotel
Nashville while Belle is still thinking
I finally
understood you know I had an elimination
because I was trying to understand
why it's idea of course so why white is
waiting actually why Alexander is making
all these moves like Bishop F4 King H1
actually she wants your queen to leave
the E6 Square why is it important first
of all I mentioned the G4 idea but also
um let's see I will make a move which
will not be king H1 and I will make
something like A4 so what would black do
in this position and now you can
actually play Queen B6 because after
Bishop G5 your standard plan then I
actually want to play C4 King H1 and as
you can see now even if you will play
here F4 Bishop F7 after Queen F3 I will
have this breakthrough D4 right so I
think it's important to understand what
you're trying to anticipate so here
after Bishop F4 Alexander waits for
Queen C6 because you can you cannot play
uh here Queen B6 because your Pawn is
hanging on D5 so I will take a Swiss
check so Rook d8 is a very natural move
here so King H1 once again I am waiting
for your queen to make a move and of
course you want to put your knight on uh
E6 but after Queen C6 here I think that
now you can execute your plan F4 Bishop
E7 and G4
wow it was no no no not here no no wait
a second it was after Queen B6 sorry not
Queen C6 yes because now D4 of course is
a check check yes it was Queen B6 right
here yes this is I analyze so uh here
you can play G4
and now because the king is on H1 as
opposed to ps31 you're you're you're
happier to being on light squares and G4
looks like a nice way of opening up your
Bishop
and oh thank you for that and uh once
again as we came up to the penultimate
round quit checking and understandings
and our favorite game of what if if Anna
zatoski were to win her game and Bella
where to lose and if Irina doesn't win
her game that and Anna wins the
tournament today and that's that simple
and clinch is the Grand Master norm and
the 45 000 and the Karen's cup title
what else all our hearts and our hearts
there you have it and just a reminder
Elizabeth pets even though she is
currently in the third place uh she's
taking a bite today so she can't get
gain any points and our last round since
Aya shinsaya will be taking a buy and uh
well shinsaya is playing a very arguably
the role of a spoiler today she's up
against Anna with the black pieces and
after H7 H6 there's been the trade and
Anna seems to just be thinking about
whether she wants to play B4 or if
she'll go after the pond
castles you go after the poem with
Knight F4 uh we'll keep it we'll keep an
eye on that and by the way Irena has
played your move 97. I wanted to ask
what did happen in the game oops I'm on
the wrong game Sorry night well first of
all we saw uh F4 from before A Very Yes
not the G4 B5 so the whole idea behind
F4 is B5 is going to be met by E5 so
Knight to D7 and this is where we had
that nice little tournament Bishop D4
yes and the idea was funnily enough B5
E5 no I think he wanted Knight D5 here
yeah but uh the the the line where
Almera was saying that was after okay
rookie eight E5 why this one in here
white the the the engines were going
nuts they're going look look look look
uh whites uh got a really really big
Advantage so uh
Bishop D4 yeah um so okay it's not a
good move Black's still supposed to play
B5 and allow Knight D5 and I think the
simple response to that is just Bishop
d8 okay yeah I guess I was waiting for
B4 I don't know what I should be doing
so something silly let's say G4 B4 then
I was going to jump right something of
of this nature well we're getting to
that point where it's time to check in
with our good friends at Q Boutique and
ask them what's our daily special for
today and
the answer is we have uh men's and
women's polos you've seen the ladies in
their polo shirts this is the official
Polo of the 2023 Karen's cup chess
tournament crafted for 100 polyester
featuring The Karen's Cup logo on the
left rest and the St Louis chess club
logo on the back of the collar stay
comfortable and stylish while you make
your next move available in men's and
women's Style
exclusively available at Q Boutique St
louis.com
and we're going to see you on the other
side of our commercial break Susan
[Music]
St Louis is back with nine major
tournaments throughout the year seasonal
Classic Events are back the summer chess
classic August 2nd followed up with the
St Louis Norm Invitational and the
winter chess classic wraps up the year
in December September brings back
everyone's favorite chest night on legs
where some of the world's best don't
even know what's coming and compete for
a 150 000 prize fund 30 players across
three Fields come together in St Louis
for the U.S juniors girls and Senior
championships starting July 15th in
partnership with U.S chess the best in
the U.S fight to be the nation's best
and a four hundred thousand dollar prize
fund in October as the U.S and U.S
women's championships takes place in the
chess capital of America a year full of
action-packed Chess is just getting
started all broadcasts are available on
our St Louis chess club YouTube and
twitch.tv channels
foreign
[Music]
sure
um so what about you Elizabeth did you
did you play the game in any way
differently knowing that Josiah started
with three losses do you think that okay
I have some chances to stay against her
or were you playing more cautiously
knowing that maybe
no well actually today I saw like I
should test her like how good is her
Theory knowledge
so I was choosing actually a lion where
like she has to be very accurate so I
was actually like checking a little bit
in the database and I saw finally
speaking a game between Arena crush and
vashali from the Olympiad and you know
when I uh saw the game in the database I
remember that I was even standing in
front of Arena sport at this moment when
I saw this position and then I was
thinking like okay
if she knows it then maybe like I should
have some emergency escape and the
Knight G5 is a normal move but instead
of Knight G5 Bishop G5 this is like what
I briefly checked today and I saw like
the engine gave like okay about equal
but it's not like that okay if I bring
my Bishop to E7 I should be kind of safe
so that's why I liked actually the move
Bishop G5 more than Knight G5 because
from the harmony of visitors was a
little bit like more safe let's say
and then yes I mean like like I think
she was surprised by Bishop G5
but uh well probably the position is
still too too easy in a way because
after Queen A6 I can have a castle
and then it was clear that at some point
if I want to win material she will
you know have some escaping
so would you like to comment on that
were you were you prepared very
surprised by Elizabeth yeah I mean okay
I also sold the game but I didn't know
Bishop G5 was
but after I saw Queen A6 and that she
couldn't Castle a Circle K it's fine
let's do it are you two also friends in
real life like
you know each other well of course you
play a lot of tournaments to tell your
friends too or may ask that question
yeah we're friends yes of course we're
friends there's a follow-up question to
that that's why I asked that question
first uh how tough is it to play against
a friend when you're playing such
important uh tournaments it's really
tough I mean for me it's very tough I
like I always try to play you know like
some not not like not to push just to be
like normal gay
Without Really Trying you know no but
you know the thing is like when you play
a friend for example like in the first
round the bed against harika and she's a
good friend of mine I mean like Beyond
contact we are like sometimes helping
each other and like and she beat me in a
way like after five and a half hours
because of one single move and I even
saw the correct move in this game and
then I bet the wrong move and I lost
this game you know when you lose the
game and that despite the fact that this
is your friend or not you know like in
this moment you're saying like ah you
know like you know you're like you have
some kind of like like Angry feelings
with your opponent obviously but then
okay it's it's part of like our
profession we have to separate
friendship and professionalism and even
like losing to harika I mean like uh
it's not like I mean better to lose to a
friend that you lose to someone you
don't like in my opinion you know so so
I thought like okay I mean it's harika I
mean like she's my friend I mean she
even brought me something I asked her
like to bring something here which I
couldn't get in Germany and it was very
important for me to get and I could rely
her and she brought me this thing here
so why I should be now Angry with with
her because I met a silly silly move and
I lost the game because of that
so I can actually like we can separate
it also in the World Cup I I lost and
she's one of my closest friends
yes and it's not like going there it's
nice to I mean it's not nice but at
least you know that your friend is yes
yes yeah you prefer to lose to a friend
than to uh to lose to someone you don't
like at least for me especially at this
tournament there's no draw draw offers
allowed so you kind of but was it the
same like in 2019
I think like actually because of this
rule like probably Nana lost yesterday
in a way because the ending was
objectively a draw maybe they would not
have played on and maybe even in your
game at some point there would have been
a draw offer when the position became
absolutely I got the pawn right yeah
yeah I could have just yeah okay no so I
mean like I think actually it changes
some results uh in a way especially in
unclear positions they play it till the
end even so objectively it's a draw it
may change because of the energy level
for example yeah also like we're
checking sometimes for example if there
is some some complicated position and
your opponent has less of time and you
know that it's dangerous sometimes you
can just ask for a draw and you know
because they has less time they can just
agree and you're safe yes and I mean
like your opponent loses time because
he's thinking about that like whether to
take the draw or not and sometimes
actually like it's a kind of psychology
psychological parked so it's very nice
especially you play someone weaker and
you're a little bit in trouble and you
just like want to force her now to
decision whether to play on or not then
it's a perfect moment to ask for a draw
yeah especially if they are like really
close to that for the moon yeah I love
doing that yeah
all right let me give you a question
outside of the chess area for a little
bit and that question is if you weren't
a chess player
what profession would you choose to have
which one of you would like to answer
that first you go first oh well I know
the answer I would be an opera singer
opera singer Yes actually it is but I've
watched a lot of you are uh yes in the
past I I had this hobby at some point
but then nowadays actually I wanted to
go into yodeling
foreign
and I even found the teacher but then
like you know I I get I got the lesson
with her and I wanted to continue and I
said to her like okay now I'm busy but
maybe next month and then she stopped
teaching because she had some personal
issues
so my dream of becoming a yodeler
actually disappeared in this moment and
it was a little bit upset because I saw
like okay next to Opera Singh your link
would be a nice technique to learn
interesting yeah so in order to make
jeans are less uncomfortable I will say
what I would like to be which would be
probably an actress okay yes no I think
I'll be the still a sportsman that I
don't know which sport for boxing boxing
or swimming yeah
I love a lot of your your intense looks
I feel like you would you integrate with
that too yes you can switch into chess
boxing it's popular nowadays so it's
gonna be my opening then well not me
because I'm not your weight class
unfortunately
but I think I saw some videos I think it
was uh Andrea bought us is actually
quite good yes yeah borders against Dina
was the more defensive one and modus was
like she was like really like so active
yes I mean I saw the video oh actually
Andrea also did another boxing with
someone else who was in the chess player
it wasn't a chess player it was someone
so maybe I would pick her no but
actually she would okay at the scene is
like chest wise of course you're like
stronger than her but from the technical
point of view like what I really liked
about her when I saw this boxing matches
like that she was Fearless while I had
the impression that Dina was trying to
hide as much as she could because like
Andrea had this kind of impression like
I don't care I'll just teach you though
I will go and so I mean I really like um
okay I mean that's the only chance to
win no because she's a chest while she
was like uh yeah yeah
Dina is stronger chest wise this is true
I have one more question and I'm gonna
switch it to what I asked you so this
way you'll not be prepared the question
is uh do you have a preference in which
chess pieces you're playing with
for example you know these way these
days
keyboard pieces yeah but like do you
have a specific preference are you
familiar with the different ones that
they are you know there's the Fisher one
yeah I think I like this one more than
we have in the venue now
go out there okay yeah yeah it's like a
sound don't know like the Shelton issue
tournament one usually they use this
downs and yeah they use this one these
are the regular ones but now you play
with heavier pieces say I'm more heavy I
checked the weight yeah they're not good
for Blitz but for like classical chess
they're perfect but for plits I would
even say they might be too heavy
because I checked the weights because I
was feeling like when I was adjusting
the pieces like now in the chest club
that the pieces are I mean the horsey
looks like very nice it has a very
specific look I mean you see like I
really study these pieces but I can see
that's good I'm glad my question didn't
just go on to like one but as I said for
Blitz it might be too heavy
a bit and at home when you prepare do
you care about what you're using or
you're just using the engines these days
uh
I have a nice work with me no I don't
have more you don't have a board no oh
my God okay no why do you need it
because I'm not your age anymore so my
memory is not that good so like
something
but that means like when you look at the
screen is your age come on no but you
know like when you repeat on the screen
it's not the same as if you repeat on
the board and sometimes I have the
feeling that I would forget it so for
example like today I checked like on the
board everything
[Music]
no but sometimes especially like when
you have to learn a lot and when you
have to look like for the side moves and
it's like and you cannot like apply to
Logics because sometimes you have
positions like there's no logical thing
at all so I mean in order to to to
memorize it you have to get some kind of
you know help in a way to say to myself
like it will never happen on the board
and then I'm free
so we have all generation I'm with
Elizabeth on this yes I'm the
conservative one you know I I do carry a
chessboard with me but I didn't do it in
your age
but since like I'm 35 I saw it like I
was going abroad when I was like 10 8
Maybe
yeah
all right girls thank you so much for
all your time I wish you good luck for
the next time thank you
thank you
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our standings after round seven we
have Anna satonski lead in the
tournament with four and a half points
following closely in the second place
Bella Hoten is really with four points
and Sharon third Elizabeth Pitts and
Irina crush with three and a half
Elizabeth enjoying a bi day today what a
what an interview I wanted to say you
got two chess players together and they
get themselves very excited as we take a
look at the penultimate round pairings
taking place right now a question UK is
playing Hotel Nashville
planes of ninja it mama dada is playing
crush and our tournament leader
zatotsuki is facing Abdul Malik and
great great positions uh really good
Fighting Chess and I just wanted to jump
to Almera because she was making this
very nice points about what was going on
in Alexander's but uh
Alexandra's position with Bishop F4 and
King H1 over to you Almira thank you yes
sir and Bella has just made the move but
before I wanted to finish my thought
because I showed you a lot of this
variations so to resume if black plays
Queen B6 here so our idea is to take
player four Bishop B7 and G4 and of
course why this is so strong because
here you can take with the queen on G4
so if you play Queen C6 here that was
the line that I haven't had a chance to
show you after if sorry it was here
Queen C6 then you'd take of course you
can no longer play G4 here because of D4
but then white plays Queen F3 and you
cannot play D4 here because you're well
your Pawn spins so Bella made another
move that I didn't even consider here
she played Queen C8 but of course now
that you know all the ideas and this
position and one why Alexander was
trying to lure her opponent to play this
move Queen B6 is that Bella needs to
keep an eye on this G4 Square so let's
say if we want to play according to the
standards here and we will make this
move G4 here but now black can take and
if you play five because you can no
longer take on G4 okay we are going for
our standard breakthrough in the center
D4 right
so this is a very sharp game if
Alexandra will take on G5 so what should
you do here I think after Bishop Queen
C8 so Bishop G5 Bishop G5 F4 once again
it's a standard idea but after
um Bishop is seven maybe you can try
Queenie 2 with the idea of Rook D1
which seems for me quite natural here
what do you think yes sir and I said I I
don't like your G4 I think that is
incredibly challenging after after uh
Bishop E7
G4 takes
F5 and uh well if I could play Queen
takes G4 I'm a happy camper right but
now the whole idea of this move is
actually to play D3 and to shut your
Bishop down disagree I think white is to
prepare it a little bit we need to Rook
D1 seems more natural to me and then
prepare G4 it's it's my natural
aggression you see it gets in the way uh
all the time Queen takes G4 D3 Bishop D1
I guess you play C4 and you're saying to
me my my great attack on the king side
is not going to uh achieve much actually
C4 might be a bit premature because Rook
given that was my question of course
maybe you should prepare uh
um C4 and also bury the Rook G1 thread
so what can you do here can you play
Queen D7 a lot of strange moves in this
position yes because you're right
protect something so and especially
actually after Rook G1 Queen D5 check so
why is it at the end of the road Rook G1
Queen D5 check Bishop F3 Queen tag C5
yes
defending upon him and Rook E1 just
simply queen of six yes I think that Dr
rookie one Queen F6 and you have a very
healthy cookie yeah exactly I was so
excited rookie six Queen F7 and the
sixth and queen of seven wow okay let's
thank you for that um really uh well you
you you managed to throw us at the deep
end of the pool we really got uh pulled
in there let's take a look at our
tournament leaders game Anna zutanski
for a second because when we left it
Anna actually had some really compelling
choices I think the first line you kind
of look at is like what happens if I try
to get rid of my backward Pawn B4 what
happens if I try to Castle castles looks
pretty attractive you know maybe I'll
post my Rook up on d8 I suppose black
would try to bring her King into the
center with Rook dating and it is always
something to be suggested for
development development with E3 bishop
and finally and the move that Anna chose
Knight F4 in Anna's mind she could be
thinking of G4 and knight uh to H5 as a
way of grabbing a pawn Knight to C6 on
the board and from she's been thinking
here for a long time on the B8 is on a
Black's agenda yes she's probably
considered a knight H5 Knight H5 right
and in this case you know I'm a pond
Grabber I like to keep my pawns too so I
will probably play here I was surprised
in the variations that Almira was
showing us where black just sacrifices
the pawn and they have enough
conversation right something like Rook
d8 Knight takes King f8 and as the
computer was showing the dynamic play of
King E7 you you well let let's be fair
we have invested a great deal of time in
capturing a double Pawn I don't say the
end game so I'm not that worried about
being so behind in development right
there is a consideration though Nasi
that I have for honors fans and that is
okay if you let me play muruk d8 if you
let me play Rook B8 and that will come
with the tempo don't forget I have
Bishop A6 at night uh A5 we've been
talking about a targeted Pawn on the F6
Square well let's talk about Rook B8
Bishop A6 and Knight and Anna could
start to get worried about her Pawn
I mean either way whether I go Knight H5
or not I think that's Black's plan right
how should uh Anna prepare for it well
again I I for for me I I think you're
going to have to play E3 one day I mean
there's gonna come a time that you don't
want to face Knight D4 and you don't
want to face Knight D4 and Rook B8 so
something like E3 to get things started
seems right into Castle short or long
you're not sure I'm not sure but I guess
long I guess if we're cast online long
maybe we should start with long Castle
because okay who knows maybe instead of
e3 we will play G4 and develop the
bishop the other side the other side
okay so castles long and I think that
the moves Rook B8 and Rook d8 are
necessary in my mind if I'm playing the
black pieces I would love my king
actually to be on E7 that that's safe
it's in a pocket but it also protects
the D6 Square the F6 Pawn so Rook d8 yes
and you're suggesting G4 I white has to
this is a critical moment how do we
finish our development right right since
your King's going to E7 it feels like
the king side is going to be a little
bit abandoned especially upon on H6 so
maybe white should play on the king side
with okay
with G4 and uh well not a not the
biggest of surprises for ourselves but
Anna is burning her clock if she's
considering her options here and again I
do see that black is playing Rook d a
knife a king E7 and Anna needs to
coordinate whether or not she's going to
be playing for the king side like you've
suggested with G4 and finally once again
from the current position
I'm you know if I was going to play B4 I
would have wanted to have done it at a
turn ago but
I might even consider this move Knight
to D3 because once again I'm a little
bit fearful of ending up in a situation
where I have the backward Bond and you
have easy play both B2 and C4 pawns are
quite weak yeah and uh I well okay Anna
is in a key moment let's just leave it
there let's jump uh to uh Arena crushes
game for a moment because we did see by
the way Knight D7 and G4 and G4 no
Bishop D4 just immediately G4 and
there's something about this move that
maybe
um
me too I thought B5 was definitely on
her agenda for something she didn't like
about the queen on C6 exactly
and maybe it might have been E5 related
like she saw some variation and
basically she's saying to to White okay
you can go ahead and play your G5 but
eventually I'm going to get there with
my play too I'm gonna play B5 and B4 I
see this as a very very double-edged
position and white can go G5 right away
or you can go H4 here yeah and predict
black snacks mode E5 and this is a race
checkmates first exactly who gets there
first with the mostest uh definitely a
nice one to keep our eye on let's jump
to the game of harika and not enough
we're following kind of following our
analysis exactly when we left it 90 I
think I did play 95. Knight C3 Bishop B4
and
no captures on uh C3 it just happened
you can there's one more book so it
takes B5 and Bishop C3 Bishop takes C3
and I'm anticipating B to take C3 and
probably well
harika's thinking here yeah there's the
E4 option Maybe
E4 option didn't
cross my mind I was thinking you
if you play e takes D5 are you aren't
you helping me in some way let's say I
just go back isn't this oh you could do
this before it was still Knight C4
that's a cute one yes
yes okay that Bishop on G2
lying in Amber so E4 is an option oh my
are we in theoretical water still
few games but it's not a well-known
theoretical position because it's
supposed to be better for white okay
amera bail us out and tell us what the
the state of the theory suggests about
this position well Mira was
contemplating this position
as you remember we were analyzing
previously the move C takes B5 which
allowed the move Bishop A3 which was
very natural and a deprived black from
castling so Anna
um Nana she decided to Castle first and
not to take
on B5 so here after well I analyzed
actually the movie four and I think it
just happened on the board but beef
previously in the position in this
position we take C3
she takes B5 happens so and here every
almost everyone played Bishop A3 okay so
rookie eight now E4
so let's say what happens after Queen C3
Bishop F3 a queen of three attacking on
F7 and attacking the Knight on C3 right
so well you will have to play F6 but
this is a very probably the only move he
has two builds lines so I don't even
want to go there but now what I like
about this position I don't know if
harika has prepared this that here you
have this crazy move G4 and okay look at
your powerful Bishops at your Center and
the move G4 is just asking to be played
nice real really reminds me forcibly
reminds me of a games of forest Galvin
where you would have E4 and G4 in fact
harika played the move E4 and tell us
about the current position so the
current position I have very few games
and well I would have to trust the
computer here because after before I'm
not sure that black wants to play Knight
C7 so this is the second line but Bishop
B4 is considered to be the computer stop
Choice okay so and I still have a few
games here but it takes D5 C takes D5
you can take on C4 you better take that
pawn immediately I would think yeah so
yes of course you cannot take on C4
because I will take this beautiful Rook
but after Knight C4
um
you can see that this B5 pound is one
important it's a key element to this
position because it deprives black from
the possibility of developing the Knight
and also I threatened to play B6 at some
point so what should you do here should
you attack the spawn immediately Bishop
D7 let's go that's what I thought yes
that's for me this seems quite natural
and I still don't know what is the the
answer to this move because
it seems to me that Queen A4 is the only
move okay or maybe Knight T3 but after
Knight E3 you can simply take on A3 and
what about B6 just pushing the pawn
let's see B6 B6 here maybe A5 do we lose
because you threatened to play B7 B7
would be embarrassing yeah how should
they how can I show it let's say Bishop
B5 and B7 it's uh and we're not only one
in a rook we might be getting a new
Queen but after A5 supporting the bishop
on B4 so you no longer attack it with
Queen A4
um you will have to fight for a dear
life I think now the evaluation has
changed completely so maybe Queen A4 and
with the tempo attacking the bishop on
A4 here and the computer still suggests
A5 because you can no longer take on A6
this Pawn is pinned
slightly better for white Bishop before
maybe
and the Knight on B8 is still um
as well it doesn't have prospects for
the moments you will have to play maybe
bishop B8 97 Knight B6 right uh the move
Bishop D7 besides Bishop D7 also
possible Knight to David seven just uh
first of all stopping the B6 B7 but
maybe just on a good day
preparing Rook B8 Rook takes B5 yes
let's say what can we do again are you
stopping very simple plan I will play
Bishop before that's a good move I
definitely right but maybe a five uh is
a very good move in every position here
right yes if you take on A6 on person
then you simply exchange this powerful
pawn and after Bishop A6 I think black
is even better right and my knight is
now pinned I love the structure for
Black by the way uh one massive Pawn
structure versus some split and scraggly
pawns for white but yeah A5 so uh
harika's opening I want to say after
Bishop B4 by the way Bishop B4 on the
board
um what's the what's the theory what's
the theoretical uh statistics tell us
about this position well I have a very
old game and I think there was a second
game somewhere in the correspondence
database but it takes D5 is the well is
the best move in this position so she
she will have to go down this line uh I
cannot it's a piece after oh yes so you
will have to take a piece here right and
she takes D5 Knight C4 I was wondering
what happens after it takes D5 but I
think maybe you can simply take the
spawn can you take b66 sure yeah zombie
type C6 is a very human natural move but
on the other hand I would be worried if
well I might lose it one day exactly uh
let's jump to the game of arena for a
moment we haven't uh and again I just
for me I love these games where uh the
the kings are on opposite flanks because
when you know everybody plays tight you
know you want to be conservative you
don't want to lose it so when you Castle
on the same side everybody Applause you
and says great understanding when you're
on opposite sides well then the creative
flow just goes G4 Queen G5 B5 and let's
go uh your take just knee-jerk reaction
would you like to be white or black in
these positions I like this with both
okay but
rather be white because because I like
immediately F5 okay F5 and I'm already
threatening F6 exactly and so you
understand that I will meet uh F5 with
B4 here I was thinking I have Knight A4
if I had to go to B1 then I wouldn't
like it as much for white okay it'd be
very passive but I can deny A4 okay
okay and uh you wouldn't be afraid that
the Knight is somewhat
um offsides a little bit it is but I'm
using at least one piece to defend my
king side and I'll use the rest of my
pieces to attack
black skin and Almira forgetting about
the chess engine for uh oh sorry uh I
was just going to ask you're the same
question but I'll answer uh the question
first for me strangely enough I actually
like the black position and why is that
it has to do with Kings
I think you're gonna have to play King
B1 to tuck your king in one day you know
you're gonna have to get off the C file
and I've already got my king on G8 you
know and I just feel like that extra
Tempo could be meaningful now I'm gonna
ask Arena after the game why she felt
she needed Queen C7 yeah because I would
have gotten on with business uh the
other thing I wanted to ask you when you
play the move F5 does it concern you
that you're giving me this E5 Square yes
or no positionally it concerns me but
this is such a sharp position I'm going
F6 and right like we said before every
Tempo here matters
yeah while your night is pretty I think
I might be already winning yeah you took
on F6 I was expecting Bishop Bishop to
d8 uh asking you uh yeah it looks like
you're Rook G1 check King h8 right I
mean uh you've got Queen up two queen F2
I mean it feels like white already
winning like it should be just over
right yeah and this is uh exactly what
we're we're looking at all right but uh
we're going to take a pause in our
analysis and bring on a very special
guest with Almera
yes I am joined in the studio by our
very special guest Janna Thomas welcome
thank you uh Jenna you're the Scholastic
coordinator
um at the Saint Louis chess club please
tell us more about this very special
program okay well our Scholastics
program is a great program that allows
us to reach out to students in many
schools we're in I'm sure over a hundred
schools at this time adding schools
every year
and definitely servicing more than our
what we thought was 80 000 students
we're topping that now so since the
beginning of the program these are the
numbers yes
and what is your favorite aspect of the
of the program how does it affect the
students tell us well my favorite part
of teaching chess is relating it to life
think it's an important game to learn
because it can be used as a tool for
achieving goals
so students
will first have to be aware and that
takes Focus which we develop but they
have to be aware of their position or
situation on the board and in life and
then they have to accept that reality
and start their trial and error of like
building opportunities and removing
obstacles on their journey to their goal
and so that is exactly what they're
doing on the chessboard and I've seen
them absorb that and then transfer that
from the board to life and that just
that is very rewarding for me
well actually it was a part of this
program program but in the Soviet Union
so I wanted to ask you at what age kids
start
as soon as they can most of our youngest
students are around four to five yeah we
have
taught some preschoolers most of our
classrooms are going to be kindergarten
and up
okay and I've heard there are also
summer camps where uh well which lasts I
think for one or two weeks where
children can learn for several hours a
day absolutely we have so many camps
this summer uh summer is extremely
popular last year was our best year and
we're looking to service at least 50
percent more students this summer we
have space in all of our camps still
available and thanks to our partners
Ascension Health we're able to have the
summer camps in the Jennings and
Ferguson Florissant areas so we have
lots of camps to offer and if anybody's
still interested they should go to our
website and feel free to contact us
about registration
well tell us a little bit more about
this because I would imagine that it's
like Rolling Stones concert you know the
moment you have the announcement so
every spot is taken do you have a few
spots left absolutely we have plenty of
Splats left because we are trying to
have camps as big as 50 to 60 students
right so we have various levels for
students to learn it it's not just
Advanced we have intermediate and
beginner students so all students are
welcome so they should simply go online
and fill in the application yes yes and
if they have any questions make sure to
email or call us because we'll get them
straightened out yes so it's important
of course to have all the information on
Saint Louis chess club.com
dot org I think dot org yes and uh this
is a wonderful initiative you know it
brings back a lot of memories from my
childhood so thank you so much Jenna and
well please join uh this program and the
summer camps yes definitely come on out
join us thank you uh Jenna for all the
work you do it really it is a treat here
in the St Louis a summer time because
they have so many summer camps uh
varusian is just completed like
literally a day ago uh the summer camp
there and you see all of the kids a few
years ago I was lucky to teach all girls
summer camps right it was wonderful yeah
I was here boy I think about 10 years
ago for
um the American chess Camp uh Greg
shahadi uh helped that and all of the
kids it's just the it's the kids it's
their faces they're just so happy to see
you uh turning our attention back uh to
our tournament for a moment because I
really did not like the move then uh
just played in this position
uh Knight C6 was fine no no problems
with ic6 Knight H5 F5 was fine castles
okay I see a pawn uh Knight F uh six
check Knight takes D7 I'm going to
defend the pawn and I'm gonna bring my
king again uh to to my mind these were
like literally forced moves like like
you've got to play these moves uh
jinsaya played the move F6 and I really
don't like that move I mean
I'm repelled by it uh in fact uh the
first move that comes to my mind I'm a
pawn grubber I will go Rook to G Rook to
D3 pardon me
and yes I'm very much eyeballing Rook G3
check and Rook G6 like that would be a
first another one for me to me would be
Rook G1 and G4 I have a similar please
uh Instinct but I want to play G4 right
away
wow
okay
so aggressive
who was your coach again okay and
explain why
it feels like black skin is very
vulnerable now because it's not going to
the center way it was supposed to right
where it would hang out happily in the
center and you want G4 so you can open
up uh here I don't know if I should play
H3 right away or okay I also want to
sneak in Bishop G2 because if allowed I
will take on C6 and play Rook D6 and
just have a fantastic end game I like
that and the the thing I especially like
about Bishop G2 in this position yeah
exactly that there's no Bishop B7 Rook
takes D7 and if you do as you say sneak
in Bishop say take C6 and Rook G1 that's
that feels like play on one goal I mean
so Anna
well she's playing well let's remind
everybody that she won all of her games
with the black pieces none with the
white pieces she's having a great result
but she's only been drawing without now
she has Advantage with the white pieces
when it rains it pours it's all going
her way
um
Elmira break the tie uh G4 Rook G1 as
well as Rook D3 uh we like Anna's
position how good is it
it's actually quite good and John says
last move F6 was clearly a mistake but I
wanted to explain it of course it seems
ridiculous now but here you want to make
a very natural move Rook B8 right but
here comes the stunner Rook D7 that's
the nature of the mistake I think the
Josiah saw this idea and she was
thinking of like how do I make this work
right that's F6 so but after she could
have played Rook d8 right
to avoid Rook D7 as well
instead of Rook B8 yes yes Rook did but
of course but she she didn't well she
could have played this move before so
when I think that she wanted to keep her
Rook here but the computer actually
loves your move G4 Nazi in every
position so I think it's actually a very
good try but especially after F6 here G4
so if take G4 you can play Bishop G2 but
I really like Rook G1 as well yeah yes
the king is very vulnerable here so F5
and H3 maybe here so what uh what can
you do here because this is this is a
very nice pound on C8 yes right it feels
like a disaster actually I mean it looks
like maybe King F7 you have to run and
after take on D4 you you really don't
want to take on G4 because after Rook G4
um The Rook G7 is coming so and if you
play Rook G8 I just wanted to illustrate
a very simple variation that maybe you
can play Knight F6 take on D7 and this
position is completely lost I'll sign up
for that one give me the pawn I'm
actually surprised that engine was only
showing plus one right
okay so we go to you almero and we're
thinking white slightly better and the
engine goes plus three we go to you at
the moment that we're thinking plus
three and it only shows plus one because
it really feels like and and maybe it's
just the nature of the position once we
play G4 Bishop G2 Bishop takes C6 it's
so clarified that it's done and dusted
that G4 it's actually a bigger Advantage
than uh that than we think I love G4 I
love Rook D3 I love
I love uh White's position
I love Jets
and I love the horsey
we switched from a positional end game
to a very sharp Dynamic end game if
someone plays G4 especially exactly well
our tournament
see I think also for me chess is a game
of confidence seriously Anna has
suffered in her career I think due to
bouts of lack of confidence and when she
you're having a result and everything's
going your way you feel the move G4 has
to be played and you just do it
she didn't shy away from it because of
her tournament situation exactly because
she is leading the tournament and she
doesn't want to go to risks yeah to take
too many risks but positions asking for
G4 and she plays what position is asking
for so and again the Soviet annotation
the move G4 fits the requirements of the
position it meets the requirements of
the position G4 looking very good and
then that puts the pressure on Bella
let's take a look at her game
as she tries to keep Pace boy this is
these Bishops of opposite color middle
games they can actually be be quite
testing a takes B5 very crucial moment
and I wanted to ask D3
can I a moment ago we were putting the
pawn on D3 right and trying to kill the
bishop Bishop takes I've got C4
B1 okay Bishop B1 uh I took us
oh that's that's a part of apologies
that was my mouse slip Queen B3 check I
guess I'll move my king queen takes B5
right and this Pawn is sitting on the
doorstep of the position D2 well
C4
um if black can keep these pawns oh boy
well it could be it could be game over
actually that's a big if but okay D2 uh
it might be that the pawn just gets
blocked
blockaded I mean sorry
um
Bishop's above is a color position but
double edged it really it and uh Bale is
out of this one uh uh Again The
annotation would be
Dynamic equality or both sides have uh
chances to win uh what's going on Elmira
well here I am through your rescue
the blunder woman blender woman let's
have a look uh the computer suggests a
takes B5 first because he wants to keep
the tension here in the center because
uh if you play D3 immediately well first
Bishop B1 I think feature the newer
analysis but the computer even tries
Bishop A4 here of course it's a very
sharp position here I think that maybe
you can play C4
cement the spawn on D3 but I will always
have the opportunity to play B3 so maybe
I can prepare it in some way what should
I do here can I take on A6
what was your idea yes sir if if I take
a mistakes
um well okay I'm a pawn Grabber I'll
take it back Queen A6 I'm just hoping
that this Pawn on D3 is going to bring
me Glory
so can I can I try B3 here something
okay very easy to play and again this is
like those situations where I go D2 you
take a pawn and I just hope that somehow
this Pawn on D2 you take I'll go I don't
know Queen B6 or just getting you know
my Bishop goes to C5 maybe to E3 is a
compensation or well the computer doubts
because it's plus two and I think that
okay what actually explains the
evaluation according to the computer
because when he sees a very little
number of defensive resources then he
gives a quite a big Advantage so here I
think uh there are very few tactical
ideas which you can actually use in this
position and the D1 square is
overprotected so let's say queen F3 I
see and you've always maybe yes Bishop
C5 but then I will put my Rook on D1
let's say this Rook yeah and I'm not
sure you will be able to hold this grip
with the bishop on E3
because this is a very important
maneuver of course even if you play
Bishop B3 I can play Bishop C6 and
Bishop D5 right
and in the game in fact Pardon Me Bella
did uh did recapture simply on B5 she
did not essay D3 in those Pawn
sacrifices she just played A6 takes B5
and as we came on the show we played a
series of what ifs with one another we
said what if Anna zatonski were to win
her game and we really like her position
right she has a good chance to win
exactly if she does win and Bella loses
which would also happen right and Irina
doesn't win her game then Anna wins the
tournament today with one round Despair
and who would have saw that coming as uh
the bottom sea Anna zatonski in the
tournament uh has really been the only
player to go undefeated she's currently
at uh plus three and look at her line
score a beautiful 50 50. 50 drop 50
draws and 50 wins yes and she won every
came with the black pieces and today
she's trying to win with the white and
that seventh round is a bi day that was
where she would have played uh humpy on
round seven but I hope he would do from
the tournament due to illness and wow
what a remarkable achievement that would
be let's just jump into that game
is this Bishop G oh King Bishop G2
King F7
okay I think Almira suggested Rook G1
and H3 instead of Bishop G2 right I like
Bishop G2 and I like very much this
follow-up of Bishop takes C6 I see that
as an important move that just takes
away all of the uh fun play in Black's
position
right Rook D6 or H3 I love uh you know
just making sure that there's no team
play you know like the pawns will be
disc coordinated you light Rook uh D6
and
just looking to Grub back a couple of
Pawns and just put in the Rook on D6 to
annoy black well the other reason the
the reason why you want to do that is
maybe there's the desirable idea of E5
and Bishop E6 and no it stops it stops
being desirable the moment you see Rook
Rook have six so I like Rook D6 I like
Anna's positions on H5 because I always
say this at pieces in the corner are not
happy right is an exception yeah and
it's not dim in this particular case uh
I love rep D6 and H3
and uh by the way uh the the the uh
Karen's cup of course is uh named after
Dr uh Jeannie singfield uh her maiden
name is Kim and as a scientist uh
Jeannie asked herself well
you know yes sir all of these crazy
openings you got names for all of the
openings and statistically how do the
opening moves do like which are the
opening moves played most often and
what's your score well Genie the
scientist came up with the following
segment
all right so we've had uh Queen's game
it seems to be the most popular in this
tournament right seven times it was
played seven times and uh results two
wins for white one for black and four
draws pretty even I would say
Sicilian Defense not surprised to see
that right uh it was played six times
but oh boy it was I was about to say
yeah black players better shy away from
the Sicilian statistically you're not
doing well not in this tournament he has
four wins for weight right and Catalan
and ready both were played three times
and you want to shy away from it when
you're white don't play the camera we
had three other openings that were only
played twice but hey can I can I get a
little love for the English opening look
at that two and win 100
that's all I ask but that's all I ask
I'm surprised name so Indian was only
played twice that's it it is true well
we have more as well but you can see how
diverse the openings have been in this
tournament we've had
I I lost count a lot of openings right I
mean there are sometimes like the
players get into a Berlin Groove and
it's just sort of like you're seeing
Berlin's or you're seeing uh Joko pianos
uh too many of them and you're right
King's Indian look at that it keeps
going I black
did this ladies play almost every
opening yes it feels like a whoa
this hasn't been one kerokan game yet
that's the only one I'm missing I was
about to say I didn't see a king's
Gambit but you're right there was no
Karma
less likely to happen and no no Russian
defenses no Petros no no Berlin's very
happy to see that uh quite a profusion
and a different uh tournament than we we
used to our mirror lots and lots of uh
openings and defenses uh indeed thank
you Genie for this interesting idea very
interesting idea and now that we've been
analyzing so many games I had this idea
how many times was the move H4 played in
the opening stage you know in this
tournament I was thinking okay guys I'm
going to make your life more complicated
I am looking forward to more scientific
analysis and statistics about our games
well we may have to get our audience to
participate in ferreting out that type
of information interesting if we did the
same statistical analysis and let's say
GCT right I'm afraid to say it would be
like 30 Berlin 30 petrol right then
scattered a few other openings yeah Joko
pianos and that's it well again I just
uh bringing up the game of Anna because
I'm more than curious she and I
understand that move completely she says
look your night is not moving it's in a
pin uh your Bishop's not moving because
uh the pawn on D7 would be hanging so
this moved H yes exactly the move h2h3
is useful for me so let me play it right
away
big Applause I love this uh decision the
position for white here exactly what is
Black's next move should I accept Pawn
on H3 well if you don't have that
disability yeah I'm simply going to
attention to play Rook G8 Maybe
okay fair I think that that makes uh a
lot of sense and and he captures there
is uh
potential yeah a Tempo exactly
in which case just a second just a
second
it doesn't make sense and now I'm I'm
really find myself drawn to your Rook D6
idea especially as I've gotten in I
think a useful move H3 that that helps
me a lot I want to say and
um I don't know if the move Rook G8
really helps black a lot so this looks
tough for uh
um going to Bella's game just a moment
sorry that wasn't Bella's game no gosh
darn it I went through the whole list
and I saw the move Rook A7 on the board
and I wanted to ask
are we in I know I know these open
spanishes go for a long time in terms of
the theory where did we deviate Almera
from the theory when when I think it
started with Bishop F4 there was a rare
move that Alexander begin with Bishop F4
was rare and I don't know what the
complete novelty was maybe it was
Queen C8 because that's off the Beaten
Track where did we where did we get uh
uh the novelty uh Quincy according to
the database is the knowledge because
Queen B6 was previously played right we
know all the plants now and the nuances
and the positions so Bella wanted to
avoid this plan with G4 but let's say in
the position here
okay seven is actually the line given by
the computer so it's this move is very
strong so it yields like small advantage
to white but after d takes C3 that's a
typical it's a Tempo Queen F3 right so
Queen is six here and well what we need
to understand here is that after a lot
of Trades and exchanges so white still
kept the powerful uh postpone and E5
right here you have two options to take
on a C3 with a pound or to take one C3
with the with the queen so maybe with
the pound is a better option well first
of all you do not allow black to play
Rook D4 but and then I was asking myself
how should you proceed here should you
play B4
here probably you shouldn't because the
computer says
yes almost winning now I actually wanted
to play C4 but then it's not enough
because I will probably never get back
to spawn I wanted to create the past
found but here after B5 he says that I'm
not never getting it back a question for
you after okay seven uh dtxc Queen F3
can black just play Rook D7 and exchange
that great Rook on the seventh rank
instead of Queen E6 i instead of yes
instead of Queen is seriously by the way
I just want to say before we we stun our
viewers with the move Rook A6 I don't
know why Rook A6 is on the screen
Alexandra did not blunder her Rook
everybody don't panic Don't Panic The
Rook is actually on A7 nice after Rook
D7 you have Bishop F5 losing on the spot
it's a wonderful idea that's why I think
that Queen E6 is the only move to
protect the bishop and of course after
rookie first you have
created and you're losing your cream by
the way I find that type of a tactic so
easy to overlook because in my mind's
eye sometimes I look at the pawn on F5
and I say I've got to defend it yes I
I've got it in fact so well defended it
doesn't even occur to me that it could
possibly be on pre so Rook D7 uh it
looks like one of those moves that you
can play yeah and that's a real shock so
once again we're looking at takes on C3
Queen F3 Queen E6
a recapture and I agree you have
a fine great uh protected past Pawn on
E5 but I also have a candidate pawn and
Bishops of opposite colors is it too
much to say that the position should be
drawn or
should be closer to equality than
anything else I would I would have
thought it would be equal-ish or equal
after Rook to D2 in the position uh that
Almera was showing us do you think that
would you be optimistic as well not at
all I I wouldn't be so I was just
curious if you would uh as well and if
you had taken with the queen queen takes
C3 as Almera suggests uh the the square
is a future Outpost for The Rook I think
this is a little bit embarrassing by the
way oops the desirable C4 has a drawback
uh Anna zatonski again it's been the
Anna zatonski show and after H3
well Josiah just didn't have a an
alternative to Rook G8 it's almost like
exactly at this moment white has a free
move too because if it was Black's turn
I don't think there's a better move than
A5 for example or maybe it Rook B8
something like that well yeah A5 was
kind of
you know trying to play for Rook A6 so
it's sort of like white has a free free
move in hand what do you think about the
move Rook D6 looks it's a free move
right
again asking black what she would do and
that's a lot of options here it feels
like but I wouldn't be surprised if just
some
something very very consequential like
something that could really uh like
cement a very uh significant Edge and
maybe uh Almera has a answer what does
the Oracle uh tell us the Oracle
actually tell us that after Rook D6
black is
longer losing this game because as you
can see that it comes to zeros after
Rook B8 so we need to understand the
reason yes behind this evaluation
because Bishop C6 is his top top line
natural following natural follow-ups so
I think that you cannot allow black to
play Knight G4 or Knight E5 so of course
you need to take on
C6 edita xc6 and the thing is in this
line I suspect that he considered the
Knight on H5 is too far away from this
one so black can actually finish the
development and play E5 so let's say if
you play Knight G3 here then maybe well
for the moment I didn't even say Conifer
so maybe King is seven
okay where should can you take care no
because you have this bishop B7 right
yes it's a very important tactical Motif
in this position so let's say you will
play Rook G3 or Rook D2 but then maybe I
can take on H3 Rook H3 and this becomes
some clear so book G6 Knight D4 oh but
here you have a five and black is much
better so you see how careful you should
be so
um
yes not the way so I think maybe you
should try what I liked about Anna's
movement that you should open the H file
as well so let's say Rook G4 here you
can take with the tempo can you take
Rook C4 here that's a check yes it's a
check let's say King B1 but then D takes
I now you can place in group G1 followed
group G7 yes of course this position so
you don't have time for this one grab
then D takes C6 and maybe should you
bring no you have no time for this as
well what can you make here B3 B3 oh yes
B3 is the only move in this position to
claim the advantage and to keep the
advantage actually so you see it's it's
not that there's even one move you can
lose your advantage then the position
requires a lot of calculation and
precision
and uh for those of you joining us late
just to remind you of our current
standings
following is Bella Hotel Australia with
four points out of six and uh shared in
third place Elizabeth pets and Irina
Crush Alexander costume they're at 50
and it's all about tomorrow and the
championship round the pairings are
going to be crew
and there it is the pairing for the
event right the two Americans will face
each other in the final round Irina
crash against Anna zatoski
and uh I think that would be the most
likely be deciding of the title well
Bella and harika too absolutely that
could still be a game to decide the the
title and we're gonna just take a short
break and we'll see you on the other
side of the break
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why just as
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone I'm here with
International Master Anna zotonski Anna
just won a beautiful game today
congratulations Anna yeah thank you how
do you feel I feel wonderful I still
cannot believe that I won this game I
was
very tired very tired working so hard
during this game it was very like almost
like almost game I won very long game
and you had the black pieces too and
I've won all my all my games with black
pieces this is something I think only
because my opponents like they're trying
to prove that white has advantage and
but endgame knowledge is important isn't
it it is but I don't know like I already
said an interview I have I had feelings
that I should not win uh this phone and
game so easily
I think the I think the Rook end game I
think it was the broken game actually
this okay I was not happy when my
opponent exchanged nice but on the other
hand I was happy too because I will not
blunder anything so because this game
this is just such a pleasure to play so
you can play like with so many random
moves you can place like 100 moves and
you were still much better of course you
have the beautiful tactical idea with
Rook G2 for those of you who haven't
seen your game they should definitely
check it out it's uh is the one I guess
I also calculated my uh all the spawn
and end game after Rook D4
so it was also just in case I calculated
yeah of course
how uh I I noticed that you're managing
your time pretty good you spent a lot of
time you
think it's good time management I was
just afraid to go home and listen was my
husband will tell me about it yeah I
think critical moments are important and
again but not 50 minutes I don't know I
just was I was so like shaken afraid to
play move before I know there is a move
in such type of position fashion
recognition and you I played many
different lines in Catalan for both
colors and I know in you there is a move
before it's not like
yeah but still it was very scary to play
Move like that I understand well
yesterday you had a rest day can you
tell us what you've done in the rest day
I met you yesterday so I know but
I can tell you we were here on
Expedition it was very nice very
instructive about a little bit uh to
know about history I went to zoom but
not to see animals I tried to buy a toy
a slot
Unfortunately they didn't have it here
my son loves Penguins so I bought a
t-shirt for him and something else with
penguins Ah that's nice I I always did
you tell him already or yes yes okay in
picture
like during the game I was like so okay
nervous and excited and when my opponent
was also thinking for 30 minutes I was
thinking about my son about like his
pictures what he was doing today trying
to calm down yeah
and then I was like start smiling and
arbiter was like what happened why why
is she smiling yeah
interesting well it's nice it's nice to
know you're thinking about your family
no no no I I was like trying this it
helped me to come down not to think
because my opponent had so many
different uh yes and after thinking for
50 minutes she was thinking for 40
ounces she played a couple like quick
moves and then she starts thinking like
really really
so we should uh get rid of this myth
about chess players focusing for the
entire game only on chess sometimes
there are exception this was exception
this was for me it was the way to a
little bit come down during the game
yeah okay that sounds good tomorrow I
have a day off as well do you have any
plans for tomorrow something that
prepare like yes only like preparation
and I'm like sorry I didn't answer a
couple emails and people who I'm so
sorry I will answer tomorrow but you
know what they say you have an important
so forgiveness like some
future students maybe okay okay I'm sure
they'll forgive you yes yes focus on the
tournament preparation and uh like I'm
playing
and she's very
so
very young active player and I I want to
like please take a preparers tomorrow
and against Irina in last round as well
of course that is very important it's a
good tournament you're doing great
um I know I had a talk with you at the
beginning of the tournament I won't
mention it for now but hopefully at the
end of it we can we can bring it back up
I have one more question for you Anna
before
um I let you go could you please tell us
what is your favorite game of yours that
you played
um one with the best memories or
uh my uh probably my best uh game I
consider this is I think 2003 and
oversure this game to my students and I
think you can find it on YouTube
Somewhere I was it was a lecture in
Gibraltar I was analyzing this game and
I like this game it was because it was
kind of combination of tactics and
strategies you bought and I had this
windmill you don't usually have wood
milk usually it's like portion
recognition the idea but in your games
it's very rare So I was very happy to
like sacrifice Queen and it was no check
very simple but very elegant and so far
even it it was 20 years ago I consider
this my favorite chess game wow
beautiful okay be sure to check it out
Anna thank you so much for stopping by
to talk to us I wish you good luck have
a good rest and good luck in the last
round thank you so much
meet me at the beauty the beauty in
Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedy's romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
in Forest Park
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
q-boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parson approved the building of a
life-size chess board to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a lifelong
patron of scouting in Great Rivers
Council board member proposed that the
project be built as an Eagle Scout
project Jeannie invited 16 year old
Andrew Dowden of troop 6 Jefferson City
to take on this incredibly important
project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chess board
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite I
wasn't very familiar with the technology
needed to engrave on there so I needed
some assistance with that and learning
how to do it and after all that I'm
pretty sure I know how to do it now so
to engrave those Edge pieces I went down
to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we use the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
it ended out to be a really really cool
project so we had a ribbon cutting of
the chess board and there were a whole
bunch of people there including the
governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project Jeannie was
there I had to give a little speech that
I didn't really know I had to do but
that kind of has taught me a little bit
about speaking too so I think that has
helped me too this project it's made me
real proud that everyone is enjoying it
like every time I go down there
somebody's playing
um and then they're taking care of it
which really makes me proud because
me sinking all that time and everyone
else that's helped me sinking in all
that time I like to see people use it
but I also like to see people appreciate
it
[Music]
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our standings after round seven we
have Anna sachovsky lead in the
tournament with four and a half out of
six and closely following Bella hotness
really just a half a point behind
Elizabeth Pates uh having played seven
games gets her by remembering reminding
everybody that humpy to narrow our
defending Champion top seed withdrew for
purposes of illness and that's why we
have the games played column uh
tomorrow's
insaya will have the buy and that will
be the end of the tournament and let's
go around the chess Arena and we'll
start with Anna zatonski game because we
really light Anna's position she played
a move that we kind of frowned upon as
we were on our break we're looking at
this position in this sort of like if it
was Black's move what would black do
Anna has an opportunity she wants to
take on G4 Rook takes G4 and she wants
to play Bishop take C6 as well as Rook
takes H6 so we thought why not start
with the move Knight G3 if you play A5
in order to play Rook A6 well then we
get everything we want we can take take
and we see what we're doing suddenly it
becomes very very visible and Knight can
also come into E4 attacking C5 and go
into D6 exactly on a good day we get to
do all of that as well she actually
chose in the position Knight F4 and we
kind of feel that throws away
uh well not completely but a significant
part of her Advantage we still like on
this game let's go to the game between
Alexandra and Bella the this is uh right
out of the opening this uh open Spanish
and I have seen the players uh play
these positions quite often as black
these Bishops of opposite color
positions were expecting to move Queen
F3 hitting the uh the pawn on C3 the
bishop on E7 is under attack uh Queen E6
is our expected move of defense and
there is this oh this is an evil evil
Cheapo
um 57 walks into this beautiful tactic a
stunner actually a white would win but
after Queen E6 we think the position's
Fairly balanced continuing our journey
Around the Horn the game of harika this
very strange Catalan where whites really
the white spot structure has really been
compromised but she also has
an initiative and active pieces but I
tell you I like this last move by uh
Nana Rook A7 prepping Rook B7 right also
just freeing him herself from the pin so
she can finally take on C4 immediate
threat of course uh that uh Rook is an
ambush it's important for harika to not
forget the night and I was hanging
because it's been there for a while true
there and black could not take it but
now all of a sudden they can exactly and
after this move Rook A7 what do you
think we might need your reaction is
Black's doing okay yes I think so I have
to move tonight maybe 95 back okay it's
I don't feel like my Bishops are doing
as well as they should be oh wait a
minute you I was sorry no Knight C6
excuse me the funny part is I forgot
that after Knight C6 I can't plague I
wanted to play Queen B8 thinking that
you would have to take here and I wasn't
going to end up taking here but I forgot
that the bishop is actually still uh
hitting the Rook B7 maybe 28 here yeah
okay thank you Queen E8
all right
well we'll keep an eye on this one and
finally our fourth and final game at uh
Arena Crush
um as we saw in our standings needs well
a win
Let's uh let's make it simple if she
could win today and tomorrow she plays
Anna
I mean the first place could go to Arena
crush the championship match exactly so
when we left it a a game full of them
and vigor G4 G5 uh B7 B5 on the board A2
A3
um black was having difficulties meeting
B4 the Knight was going to have to go
either to A4 and B1 uh A3 makes sense
Bishop B7 I thought it was okay to allow
before but really yeah and put the
Knight on A4 okay I kind of saw it as a
Target myself I like A3 and I like this
position very much who's getting there
first with their attack I mean you
mentioned that if you were on the white
side you like F6 and F5 and F6 why did
she not play F5 in that case
maybe she doesn't like 95 so she
I'm so happy I got in the question first
uh we're gonna ask the Oracle that maybe
maybe just simply rolling with the
punches something like this Almera why
didn't Gurnee play F5 uh so let's see F5
uh black will play Knight E5 yeah F6 F6
is a very important follow-up in this
position of course but Bishop f8 you
know protects in everything for the
moment and uh as you can see once again
a very complex position yes a lot of
possibilities for both sides in this
position uh traditionally you would
continue with the move H4 here so you
need to open a few lines right maybe a
rook a B8 of course this is also very
logical traditional traditional so H5
the thing is like it looks uh very scary
here of course the the pounds are
already so close to your king but the
computer doesn't have any emotions so
before you continue this before right
yes and as you can see nothing has
changed so still three under the sun
it's still freezing can we try and move
like G6 here
we want to open a few files but here
after hd6 he even takes on G6 so when he
thinks that everything is fine so uh
maybe take on G7 but Bishop G7 and black
is already winning yes yes no problem no
problem so you have to be
more careful and Bishop D4 is actually a
very nice move okay and Bishop D4 I I
wanted to say uh oftentimes it provokes
the move E6 E5 because if you capture on
F4 takes E5 uh Knight takes E5 and
I don't know that Knight on E5 you're
going to be provoked maybe to trade your
Bishop actually E5 is on the board uh
Almira yeah I actually think that after
E5 and F takes C5 black can take D takes
D5
and after Bishop E3 let's say so sorry
here after Bishop E3 uh
continue with the immediate before
but maybe
um gunai after Bishop D4 she provoked
the move E5 wants to play Bishop E3 back
so now you have to take
um before otherwise I would continue
with F5 and the square E5 is no longer
available for the Knight so it takes a
four Bishop takes C4 and now you have
this very nice outpost on D5 so this was
a small concession you lost a few
tempies but on the other hand you got
this wonderful Square
but let's have a look why the computer
doesn't suggest Knight E5 here
after the um the capture and if I
because I can see now that the
evaluation is very exciting yes so uh
maybe because of this Knight D5 and all
the lines and the bishop protecting the
the pound on B2 so you can simply
continue with the move H4 so let's try
the same line as uh before maybe Knight
D5 here immediately so then it should
take Bishop D5 it takes D5 B4
maybe can we play A4 here what do you
think yeah trying to keep the position
closed by the way as you've been
discussing the possibilities Bishop D4
E3 was played uh
uh so inviting the line that you just
showed E5 takes F4 Bishop takes F4 and
probably once again Knight E5 uh it
seems to me that White's Bishop on F4 is
not as well placed as it was on on the
D4 so I'm pretty sure she didn't like
takes with the pawn yes that was
probably what dissuaded her from but
when you played the move Bishop E3 it
was funny because I'm not sure
I recognize F5 is a big position for the
threat so in other words if I play Rook
B8
and you play the move B5 and I played B4
now yeah a knight D5 I think is wrongly
time why is this so
you're right I'll do it as before
something immediate like G6
Jesus it all needs calculated it might
not work but like F6 and then oh F6 and
then including G6 wow well if I have
that a2g8 diagonal where I can quickly
Play Bishop C4
yeah there I go like this maybe F6
immediately
without the sorry G6 immediately yeah
okay yeah without F6 yes it's very G6
immediately yeah uh yeah that's uh
that's scary
uh this I kind of uh yeah because while
you have attack on B2 my king can always
run if needed to C1 D2 right and I'm
cocooned clear with the bishop and the
Knights nice
yeah she's stealing my best lines by the
way shame one a queen B7 takes on F7
this type of uh
uh again uh you're mauling my king but
I'm trying to uh to do the same
my goodness uh this is going to take
some serious analysis I mean yes sir
thank you image seven
take on age seven I I think it's it what
what about the principles of capturing
towards the center takes on H7 I never
would have guessed that how about that
principles go out the windows
okay so it's G6
Queen B7 takes on H7 I was gonna go King
okay
oh my goodness and on King G7 do we play
h8
no Bishop is seven well you can play
king queen G4 and then Rook G1 just
simple chest very simple
and we have made some F7 and G8 right
and Rook B2 you play King C1 right
and like you say you just get on your
sneakers and start running
um super sharp position and clock is
becoming a factor 24 minutes to 36
minutes how many moves have been played
uh I mean uh they've played Arena 20
moves so they still have 20 moves to go
and we do have E5 Bishop E3 on the board
takes on F4 and Knight E5
and here
I think Renee can take
25 and go Knight D5
okay that was my question uh it's sort
of like in the Alexandra game with Bella
it's a bishops of opposite color middle
game uh what do you think about this
Bishop's of opposite color window game
well like let's say I go G6 typically
yeah in opposite color Bishop middle
games whoever's attacking has an
advantage and absolutely whites attack
looks a lot more dangerous than blacks
this H4 H5 come in okay uh is it killing
though
well I'd say I
um
I'm not sure uh how are you going to
prosecute the attack I'm going to
recapture with the F Pawn and I'm going
to try to put whoops excuse me put my
Rook on the seventh and play for B4
I work on the C7 I take 100 or maybe I
should play Roque H2 before taking
okay either way uh so Queen G6 Rook H1
Rook C7 uh you're welcome to play Queen
H2 I'm still I'm aspiring for B4
so before I will respond with A4 by the
way okay
so Queen H maybe uh look F1 Rook have
six ideas there's so many ideas Rook F1
Rook F6 because if you play Bishop G7
now I will then Queen H2 and I like what
you're doing with white here uh but
we are welcome
just asking because I just wanted to let
you know
um boy
and how did they do in their head to
head they've only had one game in Brunei
won that game against Irina wow
we need more data
obviously my goodness only one game uh
between them okay very exciting game
just want to go to the game of oops
alamira has some news for us
yes I wanted to draw your attention to
the position between Harry kaderno
Valley and Nana because I analyzed it
before and it just happened so Nana has
a very interesting move here Queen takes
before I was trying to understand if
what would be the consequences of the
screen sacrifice so I will take the Rook
on A7 then Knight B6 and then a very
strong move Rook F A1 so if she sees
this line and especially uh sorry after
Queen B5 uh Bishop F1 so for example
here Queen A8 is the only move after
Queen C6 black is already losing because
I will pin the Knight
here and there is no way for like for
you to escape because I will have Bishop
C7 and I will win the Knight so yes sir
this is a very interesting Queen
sacrifice of course it is Justified
because you will activate your Bishops
especially if you will take the pawn on
B5 so let's say what happens if you take
Queen after Queen B5 Bishop F1 Queen A8
I think you have this very interesting
move Bishop D2 threatening Bishop B4 and
I like White's initiative here it might
not be winning but it's a very nice
position for white and what if not Queen
B5 here that's I still didn't have a
chance to understand maybe E5 yes would
be more human also but after d takes E5
then Queen B5 can we do the same ah
there is a very lovely idea he's
sexually should take on the six then I
will play Bishop B5 or
or it's a computer suggests Rook B7 even
with the same idea he tries to win the
night and also Rook on A1 to A7 doubling
the Rooks on the seventh rank uh first
of all I love the move Queen takes
before I think that the queen sacrifice
uh has really uh suggesting itself in in
a stroke you gain the seventh rank
you put your passer your your your your
b-pawn passer into uh Play Bishop to D4
and all kinds of ways of winning
material for white and I like this idea
uh very very much the other reason I
would be find myself compelled to play
it as if in because in the current
position
uh if I don't play the sacrifice but I
have I allowed Knight B6 and queen takes
B5 I'm simply I'm simply worse yeah uh
as as white so uh not only is it good
but it might just simply be forced uh
necessary yes uh the the one reason I
might just be a little bit reluctant and
that's in the variation you were showing
with Queen takes B5 Bishop F1 I would
just be you know thinking about Knight
C4 B3 you know I don't know
I'm I need a move like
uh I guess G5 I don't know I need to
make a Luft
I need to make air for my king to
breathe so something like a back rank
I'm afraid the desirable Rook C8 will
just provoke roxy7 and yeah back rank
mate so a make Luft or German for air
with the move G5 but yeah uh the one
thing I don't want to see is connected
passers so if you were taken on C4 D
takes C4 right okay five Rook seven a
five let's do it I will try to win this
one and your Bishops are just going to
carve up the position yeah okay
I I can very very well believe that but
I love the move Queen takes before
that's a great uh Queen Sacrifice by
harika
and as we're getting ready for uh time
trouble we better sneak in some social
media before uh the time come online
this one is from Sabine
okay this is from our uh social media
that is uh yeah Master if you will
social media so I think this question
was asked uh to the players and now
she's asking us who influenced your
chess careers the most and favorite
world champion well clearly I got caught
up in the whole Bobby for sure boom so
for me that's an obvious one Bobby
Fischer uh and just everything the most
influential and your favorite world
champion
I wouldn't I don't you see I didn't get
the chance to really see Bobby Fischer
as my favorite world champion because he
stopped after winning the World
Championship so it was sort of like I
think Gary uh was uh the most I want to
say influential person in the world of
Chess uh that essentially we used to
joke that there were two types of
tournaments
tournaments that featured Gary casbaro
tournaments that didn't feature him and
Gary was really something extraordinary
in the world of Chess today Magnus has a
completely outside influence and I think
no less a figure than Vladimir kramnik
said about Magnus that magnus's chess
Magnus is chess I mean it's like wow I
mean that's very very powerful how about
yourself jump in uh my favorite world
champion definitely Magnus Carlson
absolutely
um not only she's I think the second
highest female radio player of all time
but I was lucky that I grew up with her
we're same age I think she's even one
year younger than me so we played same
tournaments until you know she's
repressed surpassed my rating by like
500 points but I loved watching her um
growing up and I still she doesn't play
as much but whenever she does play I
love seeing her games wonderful in the
mirror same question for you your
biggest world champion influencers and
well I wanted to make a joke that I
don't even remember what was the
question because I was trying world
channel is yes one of my favorite world
champions is Mikhail tile yeah well
he he was such an inspirational figure
for me well his games were absolutely
amazing and I already told you that his
personality was incredibly creative and
original he had such an original mind
and as for the people who have
influenced my chess career actually I'm
very thankful to all my chess teachers
because they shared their chest
knowledge and chess wisdom to me and
broadened my horizons I think this is
one of the most important important
things to me as a chess player yeah
absolutely coaches are really big
outsized influence and a really
remembered yeah no I really remember
these world champions I mean Gary gave a
great deal of credit to niketon and his
seconds yeah the coaches yeah his
coaches and unfortunately the the person
who just passed away from the
um
let's just jump back into the game uh
games pardon me as Arena she went for
that that line there was a captures on
Eve this was the Bishops of opposite
colors she took took and uh well I threw
out G6 just that kind of flippantly uh
maybe I would wait uh uh to play the
move G6 she did play the move G6 and I
think this is where
h2h4 we were looking at and we're just
going to go back to this position
because uh I'm VAR uh varusia and the
Cobian is saying don't play the move
Knight E5 like just the the there's no
re reason to read uh reason to rush
because in in some ways the the the the
night could be a useful as a defensive
and just so instead just play Rook beer
and before and get on with your business
if you ever get into a situation like
this
you never know the night might be uh the
useful one on on Apple useful in the
attack with Knight C5 Knight A4 exactly
exactly so uh VAR wasn't pleased by the
move Knight E5 and the current position
um well
could be the spoiler here that would be
also her first win in the tournament
that's what I wanted to say let's go to
the game of Bella Alexandra and Bella
for a moment because we did not see
aftertakes
uh Queen F3 we saw Queen B1
that's a good move as well
it's F5 it's
um it's B5 C3 F5
that's a lot of things yeah uh Bishop H4
whoa
uh
pause I'm coming to uh the moment this
is second uh why did you play Bishop H4
for for me as well Bishop H4 B3 takes C4
give me the pawn well I mean Bishop was
hanging on E7 and sure she didn't want
to play Queen E6
because in some lines after we take
seats still walks into Bishop B3 is my
guess right Queen takes and Bishop B3 uh
Bella was fearful but it looks
strange right the bishop on H4 B takes
E3 uh I'm still facing the potential of
G3 Queen takes B5 feels like Alexandra
is going to be happy with the outcome
interesting you said that you're still
thinking about G3 because that's move I
would never push here
you win a piece my dear yes but Queen C6
Rook D2 I might lose more than a piece
okay sometimes
it doesn't always go your way right uh
but yeah I'm just saying uh it feels
like uh Bella is on the back foot she's
the one who's having to hold her uh
wheat pawns once again F5 the desirable
Queen C6 might cost you F5 Almera I like
uh White's position
you're absolutely right yes sir because
I think that Bishop H4 is a terrible
mistake didn't find anything wrong with
this very natural move Queen E6 because
what is White's idea let's say I will
take bitex C3 right then I can activate
my Rook Rook D2 you don't have the time
to take the pound on B5 I think White's
idea
was maybe to take on F5 but here after
Queen F5 let's say if you take Queen F5
you don't have the time to do so because
I can take maybe on the four here and
yeah and
there is a background mate oops you this
idea will not work so you after Queen F5
you will have
to take on E7 but then I can simply swap
the queens and then to take on the four
or maybe start with H6 I think this this
same game is pretty cool yeah so what
else after Rook D2 a very simple move
once again Bishop E5 doesn't really work
I liked
um a very human idea let's say Bishop D1
with the idea of putting the bishop on
F3 but then
your Bishop is not attacking on F5
anymore then I can play Rook fd8 and if
you play Bishop F3 I can maybe continue
with before because C4 is no longer
available
or it is it maybe then you can click on
the 27 yes okay so C4
ah okay this is a very interesting
because I analyzed until this position
so maybe I shouldn't rush with before
here
but what else can we do we already
activated all our pieces you've done
very well Bella actually already played
before in the after Bishop H4 Bishop
Pawn takes C3 she played B4 right away
so yes so this seems to be uh and why
it's uh idea to play C4 here but maybe
maybe I'm not afraid you know Bishop D5
so what what can we try here let's try
it
just to say that while you've been
analyzing uh Bishop H4
uh B2 takes C3 and B5 b4s on the board
and we're both looking at this and we're
really liking uh what we're seeing here
for Alexandra we think that uh White's
position is kind of harmonized uh very
nicely and uh well the first thing I'm
thinking look at
by the way Bell is down to 5
minutes
by the way we came on the show and
saying what could what if things really
seem to be going uh on his way exactly
at this moment as two of our nearest
Rivals Bella and Arena are actually not
doing very well at all Anna's doing okay
maybe not as great as she was but if
Bella were to lose Arena not to win
Anna wins
tournament's over uh B4
question can I take the pawn I think
yeah and Alexander already did so I
think Bella said he has to go C4
oh to go C4 I beg your pardon because if
you take I wanted to go Queen takes
before give up a bishop but to uh to
check me to Checkmate along the seventh
rank I didn't see
how how black could defend G7 it's an
awkward it's a so C4 and should and she
did play C4 given the time situation
she's down to four and a half minutes
with still 14 moves to go right she
wants to have a position where she has
some counter play where she can make
obvious moves like Rook D2 Queen C6 try
to attack right of course it shouldn't
be working white should have a big
Advantage but at least the play is easy
for black at the moment and with four
and a half minutes that's that's
important uh some initiatives some
Dynamic possibilities are mirror for for
Bella or is it just a pawn well as you
remember I was looking for the same idea
in well in a different position
sacrificed upon and before and to play
C4 but the computer you know it's it
doesn't believe us yes it doesn't
believe us and it's incredibly wild and
in its assessment of this position so
right yes white is completely winning
and he it she proposes B5 here yes the
Oracle uh Rook D2 right
but for the moment you don't threaten
anything as long as you will not create
the ideas
something like Queen B7 Queen eight or
queen C6 we shouldn't rush the things
and play B6 here uh maybe uh what can we
do actually what would be the human move
here so if we play the C6 immediately
then Queen C6 and as you can see well
yes the biggest uh part of the advantage
disappears so I just wanted to check
that we were evaluating this position
correctly so maybe Rook ah okay six
maybe so with the idea of playing Rook
C6 let's save Queen B7 here now Rook C6
and I interposed my rook and this is a
very strong idea I love it not easy to
find but very strong no especially from
the perspective the diagonal you're just
closing yes the H1 diagonal to begin
with you're keeping F5 live
under underguard I love it you know it's
funny because you want to play B5 not
necessarily with the idea of Rook A6
Rook C6 you want to play B5 with the
idea of B6 and B7 and let's get going
but in fact B6 is the wrong move Rook A6
Rook D2 I I'm Charmed I I like that very
very much it's easy it's easy to miss
besides the move B5 you would also
mentioned the idea of maybe
transferring the bishop to F3
that makes a lot of sense too that's an
it's an easy uh
easy play I want to say because if you
anticipate Rook D2 you would love to
have G2 properly defended right so is
Bishop D1 that's the only way the
advantage I'll be scared of moving the
bishop to F3 instead now C Pawn has a
direct to keep going yeah it was funny
because I was on the of the mind that
say Rook D2 Bishop F3 and then C3 yeah I
was of the mind that I I desperately
want to play E6 and E7
so but E6 Queen takes E6 is kind of like
a rejection right but if I if you I play
Bishop D1 and you play C3 then I get
check and I have E6 as a at least I'm
there right that's very unpleasant right
something that thinks uh and again the
time is huge factor in favor Alexander
has 41 minutes against Bella's four and
a half
I'm trying to remember Bella's not been
getting into time trouble has she in
this event no just this game um I guess
after Bishop F4
Alexandra was clearly very well prepared
in the opening and Bella took her time
to make sure it would she would uh
figure out what's in the opening she
still ended up with the worst position
and she is in time trouble so and she's
a pawn down let's just jump to Anna's
position for a moment because
when we have left it we left it at the
position after Rook G8 we really loved
on this position after Knight G3 after
Knight F4 we felt that she'd given back
uh a big part of her Advantage G3 takes
takes still we like White's position and
here we pause for a moment and well we
can't help but play the move Knight H5
yeah that's the other thing we do
exchange our fantastic Rook exactly we
do see that Rook takes F6 and Knight H5
is a nasty Fork well Rook takes F6 uh
you were almost forced to play this
aren't we not necessarily but I could
also on H3 and give up F6 for the age
wow wow
King E7 and hmm okay because Rook H5
means I don't have a chance of of
coordinating uh any checkmating attacks
but I can just grab page six yes and
this is two results right oh definitely
blocks pawns are absolutely terrible
terrible terrible 36. the only thing is
Bishop versus knight here Bishop's
actually not that bad
I mean if Knight makes it to E4 give it
up it's over right uh but if we're okay
so B3 Knight is trying it might be just
a really quick way for black to improve
their pieces maybe Rook G8 okay and uh
you you stop me from Knight G3 but can I
can I uh get to E4 in a different once
you uncheck
okay uh
uh King up to Rook
I want you to play Rook takes B3
why
let's try it could be one oh I see
don't tell her Elmira don't tell her
about roof takes B3
um okay so Anna is enjoying an advantage
Bella in trouble what about Irina uh
because when we left it uh we thought H4
oh she got in C3 is that a good thing
for white I wouldn't think so
C3 because black can still play before
after A5 and now it's like why it
created two problems
two hooks
I liked
I think somebody suggested a A4 against
my B4 and so C3 looks like an
excessively cautious move that may have
given Arena some some hopes here of
breaking open on the uh Queen side
Almera uh
is is there some opportunity for arena
well I'm in analyzing the very natural
move A5 in this position right because I
think that the arena is almost forced to
find something uh very concrete and
dynamic because otherwise she's going to
get mated and I was asking myself if
Bishop B5 was possible in this position
still uh black can play Bishop A3 here
right of course the computer
uh gives a Devolution that a white is
still better but you cannot take on A3
so this is already a good thing because
you take on B5 Queen B5 Rook B8 yes with
some possibilities to throw in a
Perpetual so I think that this position
is fine for black but then what should
White play after Bishop A3 and the
computer suggests
okay so Bishop D6 here and uh well
weight is still better here but I think
that it favors Arena that the the B file
is already opened and sure she has more
chances for counter play in this
position than with the pawn on B5
precisely and that move C3 I kind of
like skip of the heartbeat pair oh uh
thank you for that and you you would
also mentioned before and takes on B4
and A5 blasting away like I can't do
this right I can't do this
seems premature but after A5
I wouldn't take on B5 you would not no
that looks to scare you would you play
H5 I have to go H5 of course no I
understand C3 is just I created another
problem right and I didn't have it
before but let's take C takes B and then
still go A4 like C takes it takes A4
yeah so B3 you're into you you're going
for the to shut me down right okay so I
I'll play B well wait a minute just a
second pause so Queen A5 You're Gonna
Play Bishop B5
right
are you gonna do what's what are you
gonna do on my take on G6 first
pause pause
are you mating me I'm hoping
okay so E5 Pawn is hanging so I should
be meaning a five here we go
here we go a five on the board
um
boy let me just pause our analysis and
so A5 H5 right yes
B4 C takes C takes takes eight okay so I
think I'm gonna need B3 even though when
you play B3 and I get to play Rook C3 uh
we Mo we could both be mutually happy
but we've never played B3 you might as
well okay I'll play B3 uh
um who's getting there faster let's take
on G6 First Take on G6 first I
am I in time to play Bishop f8 to G7 if
I put my Bishop no I don't believe it
sure I don't believe and you don't have
immediate threats correct I don't on A4
with the queen and Jack made me but it
still I do
uh sadly you're right it takes a lot of
moves
so I I do have Rook C1 option I don't
know if that helps me or helps black
yeah I work I find Rook C1 as black to
be a disappointing move because it's
just sort of like it it puts the kibosh
on ideas of uh Queen C2 check you know
it takes away a lot uh by the way uh the
nice
time is ticking down and it's a two to
one time Advantage how many drills but
they still have they have 15 moves to go
and gunai has 12 minutes against irina's
25 minutes okay it feels like it's kind
of going cruising there
and uh again Arena thanks to her Victory
yesterday over harika she's back in the
mix but she needs a win and tomorrow is
all important game against Anna okay
well keep an eye on this one Bella let
me just check in on Bella okay still
thinking C4 uh harika's game she didn't
go for the queen sacrifice uh oh that's
not a good sign because we thought that
that the beef Pawn was going to get
captured Nana doesn't have any issues
not at all not at all it's just uh she's
uh
well she's done very well actually uh
and the the for those of you usually
better exactly for those who are joining
us late there was this wonderful moment
right here where herika could have
Uncorked a queen sacrifice with Queen
takes B4 and Rook takes A7 and the
tables would have been firmly uh in
White's favor that these two Bishops
are going to escort uh the uh B Pawn I
want to say in a very very nice way we
love this uh sacrifice back to Anna
what's happening oh they got exactly the
position
we're we're in
um and Almira I wanted to ask you about
this rook and Bishop versus rook and
Knight ending because it just really
feels like it's a two result game for
Anna does the Oracle agree uh the Oracle
agrees but they think that Anna wants to
seven is the move which deprives black
of everything so what can you do here
after Rook H7 you can play Bishop F7
that's some self-pinning you mean yeah
yes but it's uh it's because you want to
keep an eye on c41 because okay the
Knight cannot jump everywhere
unfortunately and take everything so
Knight G3 I want to activate my knight
Rook G8 okay so seems quite natural to
me so Knight F5
then King D6 king of six and then 93.
sorry Rook takes F7 check now Rook takes
F7 here you mean here yes
king of seven on nature six yes let's
see apparently it's Elijah no way you
would have thought these double Pawns in
this King and fun end game would bring
you some success let's try let's
continue yes would you like to play
before here I want to activate my king
of course King to E4 as fast as possible
yeah King to E4
can get for it even though you have a
few extra moves but you don't have the
D5 Square I can play King F6 here and
yeah okay weird I I I my first thought
was the king and pawn end game and if I
go to the queen side if I had gone King
C2 to B3 to A4 at the start after King
takes G8 I mean yes King Jade King C2
right I don't think that black has any
other move than King F7 right am I too
slow yes King is six so we can get four
king of five it's a race it's a race
King A5 for me yes yes guys forward
always so King E4 King is six King E3
King is seven yes king2 so we get this
position and well as you can see yes I
have a table base it says that this is a
draw so well draw a four is King D3 and
then by the way from the starting
position Rook H7 check was played by
Anna and uh zhensaya immediately played
King to D6 and we have Knight G3 on the
board threatening Checkmate in
order big Threat by the way check made
in one is a very uh
serious threat but then you can take on
C4 yeah I was about to say I thought
that Anna's idea after Rook H7 check was
to play b2b3
and then threaten the checkmate
uh maybe she has something after Bishop
takes C4 okay well let's have a look and
the game she has played Knight G3 and
let's have a look see at Bishop take C4
because doubtlessly she has in her mind
maybe she can follow up you secure a
draw Bishop C4 Knight E4 King D5 Knight
C3 King D6 94.
I would lose my Bishop
it's not that you would get checkmated
but you'd lose your bishop and that
would be disturbing yes I get that all
right
um but I would have thought that this
was a position that Anna's playing for a
win King D6 why didn't she play B3 Amara
B3 was a better move of course so King
D6 B3 yeah and that's why I don't like
King G6 even though that Bishop F7 was
self-pinning but they still think that's
the best move in the position because
you need to activate your Rook somehow
but now because the bishop is not an F7
you can take the A7 Pawn so as you can
see uh White is still a bit better here
but your knight is on H5 so
he tries I'm shocked that white is only
a bit better I would have thought it was
more than this so wow okay
for rossing surprise for me I yeah so B3
so you're saying B3 King upon me Rook to
ga I mean my desirable Knight F6 mate is
it really surprising after seeing that
pawn ending isn't winning because yeah
well that's also a shock right so I'm
threatening Mateen Juan so I'm assuming
you go Rook G1 check I'm going here so
you get out of the maid but uh oh
there's not no wind here I'm just so uh
flummoxed I I would have I would have
thought that this was winning Knight E8
Shaq Knight G7 check give me the bishop
give me the pawn
no
I'm sure both of the players calculated
this evaluate as wide is much better
right so you have this a very uh
beautiful move after Knight of Rook Jade
Knight F6 Rook ga oh sorry
sorry B3 yes Rook G8 Knight F6 I missed
a beautiful move for black Bishop F5
because of course you have to defend the
mate yes in a tactical way here and
defend the Rook also in a tactical way
and so if you take on A7 then activate
my Rook uh via h8
wow
great stuff let's catch up with the
players however because they went in a
completely different direction I'm just
going to refresh my board we did see
Knight to G3
threatening mate and one Bishop takes C4
Knight E4 check on the board here we
were looking at King D5 right and
everybody seemed to be very happy about
the Knight dropping back to C3 this this
position after King D6 I'll mail it back
over to you is this I I still like
White's position somehow even though
she's not Material ahead
um now it's perfectly equal right now
perfectly yes and the even the computer
suggests 94 and Knight C3 you can try
and play on with a rook H6 uh-huh look
H6 then Bishop B6 makes sense King C2
okay you know you're not immediately
winning anything but I think maybe in a
long run you will win the C5 pound bag
right as you can see Anna is going for
the repetition and I think that if you
take into consideration at how much is
at stake this is like mathematically uh
the best decision
but of course a draw doesn't clinch but
it does
help the Grand Master Norma she gets so
much to play for the tomorrow she'll
only need another draw that's right uh
but she'll have black against Arena
speaking of which uh good news for
Annabella seems to be going down let's
take a look-see uh when we left it we
saw the position of the C4 B5 on the
board Rook to D2 Rook to D1 so Concentra
did not find her okay six Rook C6 idea
which was like we said very difficult to
find well yeah she you were she she she
was thinking like Rook D1 if uh you give
up the C pardon me if you give up
the D file I'll play Rook to D7 so C3
sorry you were about to say C3 and here
B6 now because Queen C6 is no longer a
threat exactly I can always exchange the
Rooks that and that's marvelous right
that's great news for Alexandra that uh
I'm gonna include one more chat Queen A2
just the weekend your uh last rank
completely
I'm sorry I'm here after Queen C6 Queen
A2 check
okay so an extra delicate touch and now
we take
and why did we want our Queen on A2
because
and Anna is repeating and she's looking
at her score sheet wondering if she
should claim or not
um
I just
um sorry and continue the line if you
will uh and I'll see you seven B7 now
gosh this upon on my doorstep this Pawn
on the doorstep Rook A8 and it seems
like well you know we're here we're
getting white is losing after Queenie
for Queen Eve whoa Queen E4 oh
that's an easy move to miss I mean my
goodness Queen E4 it's actually uh
nicely had a very nice idea but Queen A2
is a mistake Queen B3 is more precise
with the same idea because you need to
keep the queen on B3 actually so it
protects the D1 Square yes everything
the queen to B3 check okay and the same
same idea is no longer available Queen
E4 with the thread of Queen E1 made is
met by Bishop takes E4 and x-ray of the
D1 Square whoa uh and by the way Bella
went down to two minutes yes C3 12 moves
to make with two minutes super double
edged position but does that mean that
white is actually winning then yes uh
with the move Queen B3 not the move
Queen A2 if you don't see Queen E4
that's your cold shower uh situation uh
check in on Arena's game very quickly
because we do have some moves in this
game too after A5
h5b4 they are following number takes
tags A4 trying to keep the game closed
on the queen side not B3 yet and the
clock times
um Irena has 19 minutes and gunay has
eight minutes for those of you who uh
don't know the the producers put it in
three-point type so that you know a
premature blindness
so that's why I need the youths to help
me out on this one what did you say
pardon me about that uh has eight
minutes and Irina 18 19 minutes okay uh
there you go now I can say eight minutes
to 18. we're expecting something like B3
and uh well
probably the computer likes white but
I'm just saying I see three results from
a human perspective it's very easy to
blunder these positions away as white
and you miss ideas from both sides
really yeah Bingo got that for sure back
to Anna because we were told a
repetition might be in store here as the
two players
they made time control no they're 10
moves away ten moves away she might
accept the draw Before Time control or
if she decides to play on
but she's down the point here so right
I don't see why she would risk and
continue to play
well I mean again if she was thinking
that that the pawn structure is so bad
from Black's point of view that it's
that she's favored a moment ago again if
you if you're joining us a little bit
late right here I'm just very perplexed
by the decision to give away the the C4
Pawn I I would have really liked to have
seen Anna play the position on after
b2b3
yeah but here I am her goal is to just
end this game and secure the Grand
Master norm and try to win the
tournament with the draw in the last
round game plus you see we'll see if
she's successful Amira over to you what
has caught your eye in this penultimate
huh she was reaching for her Rook Rook
she wants to play Rook H4
that's what she's thinking about Rook H4
so she can she defends her Knight after
the move Rook H4 she's reaching for a
rook
so she's going to play on
and
no time though
but she has less than five minutes her
Advantage has disappeared into place but
she doesn't know that she doesn't know
that she thinks that her Advantage is
still there she's playing Rook H4 she's
saying uh I stand better
well this is a little bit risky Ken
black just move the bishop
well uh first of all you have to move
the bishop because Knight C3 check and
Rook takes on the agenda maybe Anna
thinks that black had to move the king
like King E6 in that case she would take
the pawn with the check exactly that
would be great I'm gonna have to come
back and then uh on this position yeah
I've won the pawn and life is good but
the question is Bishop B3 right yes you
have to move the bishop I don't think
she's taking any real risk here right
she's just going to go check him back
I repeat that yeah I mean she's not
taking risks she's just making you
making black pardon me fine King is six
after 93 okay uh King E6 after Knight C3
let me hit let you hit let me hit you
with the old but you said you were gonna
play 94. yeah Casita well I was going to
take the pawn I'm trying to win the you
know me I'm trying to win the pawn
that's all that's all I ask because
Bishop A6 that's a different move
does that justify
uh on his decision to play for a win I
think it does
so how would you you if you don't repeat
now how do you play for a win well I
play Knight C3 check take into Six right
okay so uh let me let me ask you what
you want to do
develop my Rook okay good I'm glad you
answered because I had a very sneaky
idea of taking advantage of the excuse
me that wasn't what I intended uh taking
advantage of The Bishop's position on A6
I didn't like Bishop A6 it it Bishop B3
felt so natural Bishop A6 excuse me
Bishop A6 Knight C3 check on the board
and again
um not that Rook A4 was any any great
shakes just a kind of a cheapo or a
feature of the position I'm checking
these six
two yeah maybe I have to drop back Kings
of seven right
and here I'll hit you with a different
check and I'll come after this guy
King to D6 well uh is Anna justified in
uh pursuing uh obviously she thinks
she's better and she wants to try to
prove it Almira
well I think that black is not risking
anything in this position after Bishop
A6 yes you have like a tiny tiny
Advantage but uh with a very little
material on the board I think that it's
very close to the draw
but I really don't understand John
science decision to play Bishop E6
because indeed Bishop B3 was uh the best
move in the position but she spent maybe
a few seconds on making this move right
but hold on I I sorry uh let me let me
uh
phrase it differently I'm in Honor shoes
I think I'm winning
okay is she justified in that
perspective
because clearly she she declined a
repetition well I don't think she thinks
she's winning I believe she thinks she
has no chance to lose this so why not
test the opponent maybe she'll get a
chance to win this
and then she's justified in playing on
so for example uh in this exact position
give me a move for sansaya if you play
King C7 well then she's going to play
rookie six and make a pretty decent
claim that she's better so you're gonna
go King D7 correct and that's and let's
say I go King D2
so my idea is to go King E3 go happily
marching up the board you're going to go
Rook B8
and then I'll go Knight A4 to defend
upon on B2 that Bishop on A6 is just
awesome it starts to make a strange
impression doesn't it
and uh night eight Fortnight well we'll
keep an eye on this one because uh again
if Anna could win this game I mean she
could easily clinch let's check in on
Arena and whoa uh we've got some
moves takes takes six that's a strange
six all right why did we put our Queen
on D6
first you put moved from C6 to C7 which
we also didn't get a question yeah the
queen D6
um the idea behind too slow
um I would be tempted to plant my Bishop
over here maybe I like Bishop B5 you
like Bishop B5
taking the H or f file under control
Queen F3 Rook F1 Queen F3 Rook H1 I
don't think we should include H6 G6
because okay it's not like I'm I'm
planning to push H6 no almost never
right so and by the way opening up
either the diagonal or the file can only
be beneficial the moment you suggested
usually it's a commentator's curse right
where we say you'll never you never play
H takes G6 in these positions
yeah make that move exactly okay I was
thinking that Arena was always planning
to recapture with their F-bomb so let's
imagine F7 takes G6 just for the uh sake
of discussion however we have a lot of
options here so Bishop B5 still looks
good right
again the idea of just kind of shutting
down the queen side protecting the king
as we kind of measure up Black's King
12 minutes for arena look I might have
something more concrete as well can I go
after E5 Pawn because you can't defend
it right now so Rook
so if I go Rook G to E1 I was giving up
G5 if I go Rook D to E1 I'm giving up D5
but yeah I'm but I also feel that if I
give up the D5 Pawn I'm so vulnerable
like I start to worry that maybe I
shouldn't
uh if you're worried about grabbing a
phone yeah something yeah something uh
is that is seriously wrong I get it I
get it a double edge Precision uh Almera
what is called your eye as uh round
eight the penultimate round uh lots of
things happening
yes and that Alexandra is about to win
about to win yesterday
well it's plus five right now and since
uh she avoided all the mating threads
here in this position she can maybe take
on G2 because now you don't have your
queen E4 here so let's check if this is
possible take on G2 Queen B3 you know as
we wanted to play here and actually what
I like about these positions that here
you don't have to force things of course
with B7 because that's why Bella played
Queen C5 because I will take the the
Roku Nissan but you can make this move
yes because you force you force The
Exchange
oh my prince yes and then this position
is uh well rather willing let's say
Bishop F2 oh Bishop F2 you want to
protect or Bishop E7 uh yeah something
okay let's say after Bishop F2 I can
probably play B7 here because you can no
longer than seven years
there's some geometry going on there
Alexandra is very good at sports and
nice these tricks okay so Bishop E7 in
that case
three yeah this is Bishop E7 so maybe
now that was my idea well I will trade
queens and should I protect can I
protect do I want uh maybe rookie 6 and
B7 here yeah well I for sure after Rook
D7 yeah after Rook D7 Bishop takes it's
it's two result game anyway yeah so
let's say Rook d8 here but you will
always have this bishop right
and well we cannot leave the trunk of
course so
um maybe Rook B8 but B7 is okay so
exactly and uh Alexandra is doing
wonderfully well the times I know that
Bella's in trouble on the clock how how
bad is it Alexandra is remember before
she had 44 minutes well now she's down
to 14. so she's still burning time still
plenty of time compared to her
opponent's clock but two and a half
minutes
because these are the critical moments
if she finds the next couple of moves
the game will be over exactly
uh it still feels to me like it's one of
those positions that it's so easy to
error I mean you know because the pawn
is on C3 there's background problems for
both sides and yeah it it's really nice
for us to sit in the comfort of our
studio here at the St Louis chess club
we don't feel the time pressure and the
tension that they do but you know you're
sitting there looking at these back rank
mates for both players and it's very
easy to get nervous I mean a desirable
move like Rook C7 for example this seems
to be very attractive would it uh Queen
F2 black might be winning just like that
there's a turn around and it's so simple
it happens so quickly that Queen F2
Queen E1 and you go I'm losing so yeah
and you don't want to take on detail
because you don't want to take on D2 and
get the pawn any closer so it's
it's not such an easy task but once you
see this move Queen B3 check
King overtakes and queen A3 I think
that's really the key is getting rid of
the Queens if she notices that Rook on
f8 is hanging and she has this idea then
she'll definitely convert this yes
exactly you don't have time to take
advantage of the I mean even here it's
like one of those things that you
absolutely have to notice that you're
not lost you don't resign the game
two more
yeah if you had your opponent has to
resign the game all right yes sir just
one last thought of course you were
completely right because Rook C7 is a
very natural move right I wanted to
continue the variation instead of Rook
G2 after Queen C5 Rook C7 after
um
Queen F2
white is not losing but the evaluation
changes already but let's see
oh sorry no let's see what happens
because I found the very lovely draw
here because you can still play Queen G1
here Queen a one you would
think that you are winning but you have
this move G3 yes a very lovely tactic so
after Bishop d8 let's say Rook C6 D1
Queen Bishop D1 and then Queen A4 and
with the virtual
any good Grandmaster would see it right
away
[Laughter]
yes
nice that's a very very pretty variation
so you can't play Rook C7 I think that
Alexandra might as well find this
variation out of necessity because Queen
B3 with the idea of playing Queen A3 or
queen
yes and then Queen A3 is absolutely
necessary here after Queen C5 and also
once again Queen C5 for just uh you know
just to really go down this Rabbit Hole
Rook C7
Queen F2
Rook G1
I'm assuming Rook takes C2 right check
King
h8 yeah there we have it
D7 oh pardon me Rook
oh boy Rook diesel I I was I was about
to I was about to suggest Queen F7 in
this crazy line that uh we're on but I
want to stop myself and look at the move
Alexandra played Rook D7 and do you know
how Bella can draw here what no of
course not I don't know even know what's
going on it takes G2
be serious get out of here Rook takes G2
are you kidding me what a shot credit
goes Tovar who whispered that in my ear
oh really Queen F2 check and Queen no
you can't take on G2 you're losing
that's just me sorry are you sure Excuse
me yes oh white can't take it yeah why
can't take on G2 so
oh there's a Checkmate yeah
it's clear Jack
wow here and made on G4 that's simple
and if you go back to H1 then made uh by
uh
we we would say made by repositioning so
you reposition the bishop with a gain of
tempo tell them is that
oh no she wow well in time trouble
uh how is Rook D7 now and queen F2 upon
for black again
it's losing yes uh because now our Rook
is on the first time
seven takes D2
okay
and just look F1
oh Queen e you know what I I want a
blunder B7 Queen E1 check and Bella with
this Victory could stay in the mix oh
yes she needs a win or at least a draw
to stay in the mix we're talking of
course about playing for the first place
Queen so Rook G2 would have drawn the
game we say drawn but we don't know how
how right I'm I'm confused so
well if white makes the right move after
G2 I think white needs to play one and
find some defense but Rook takes G2
would have been a shock yes an absolute
shock now Queen on F2 Queen coming to F2
doubtlessly Alexandra
expected that move and you were telling
me Rook D7 takes D2 and this is the
winning maneuver for white because I
stopped your 21 ideas no because after
Rook F1 you still have Queen one but I
don't have to take it but then then you
can play G3
simple chess yeah then forces the trade
of queens and then it's all about the
bee Pond and nothing else to discuss
wow wow okay
so here's the Moment of Truth Rook on D7
takes D2 and uh Alexandra has all the
Time in the World to find that and the
follow-up Rook F1 is also correct yes
yes
we used to go before
control Bella has minute and 50 seconds
and Alexa down to eight and a half
minutes did this position reminds me of
some expression that your position is no
is is is is never so good that it can't
allow a howler
and this is like you take take you think
B7 right and and you're ready to make a
queen and
it's a howler this would actually just
turn the tables completely and Bella
would be winning and we do have the Rook
takes D2 on the board wow
okay that was it that was the moment of
truth and now she needs to find Rook F1
G1 is also good enough G
I mean if you see the idea why would you
put the rukunchi one instead of F1
because if I take an F4
and take on E5 I think I can I'm trying
to study your queening that's why I
thought Rook F1 was so good just
stopping it in fact I I kind of see it
as a position where black has two ideas
a Queenie one chat the big the big
threat and queen takes F4 so Rook F1
by the way uh did uh is Anna still
playing for victory
she she did play King D2 sure when the
pawn
by zero risk
she loves to end games like this where
she's slightly better she's gonna try to
squeeze and squeeze for hours
who doesn't
you you had me at slightly better
no risk Magnus Carlson's made a career
out of squeezing slightly better ending
so okay Anna's in good shape squeeze is
completely equal in games
pretty good uh I'm turning returning to
the game of Alexandra for a moment
because once again a crucial moment of
Bella who's been on a four game win
streak it was to win the game she's in
the mix and she's got this enormous
threat of Queen E1 it's so easy to miss
you you're thinking I'm defended I've
stopped
and There She Goes
Alexandra is just too good not to spot
that thread
and Rook F1 was always on her agenda uh
very nice and we think that this is
winning for Alexandra which leaves it up
to Arena
how is Arena doing and she does have her
Pawn on B3 the Quince came off in her
game okay so Queen came to D6 it's more
normal
she gave up upon did Arena the epon to
get her Bishop on this beautiful
blockading square and now with B3
maybe the worst has passed yes I think
when I made a mistake by playing Queen
H2 and allowing this sequence of
exchanges
oh by the way she could have played
Queen F3 and and then continue the
attack yes I find it interesting that uh
Ariana took with the H Pawn yes
absolutely but E4 on the board Bishop
takes B3 Bishop came back to D3 clocks a
factor both under five minutes for how
many moves seven moves but this is an
end game so it feels safe for both of
them actually is maybe Irina is playing
for for a win because let's say I play
Rook before okay and I Bishop B5 I want
to put Rook C2 and Bishop E5 absolutely
no if you can get your Bishop to E5 I'm
crying I think I just I'll just uh
Shadow your Rook right something of this
nature or you like to find another
Square for your Rook
I guess you have a draw like that yeah
yeah exactly trying to Shadow but and by
the way Rook before Central uh Rook
before what you said uh my Arena on the
board and Bishop B5 and here comes that
variation with Rook C2 I'm sure rooksy
Arena played B3 for a reason yes and
that was uh to be able to play Rook C2
and as you uh predict Bishop E5 so for
for arena that will only mean a draw
which means for Anna
she goes the good news for Anna yeah
pointing at half ahead she's she stays a
point and a half ahead if Anna wins it's
tournament over everybody she will have
won clinch first place clinched the
Grand Master Norm one our hearts one
forty five thousand dollars and all
kinds of other goodies and by the way
this last move convinces me that Anna
made
a very bold decision but a right
decision the bishop just went back to G8
and that indicates to me that the
zensaya is not liking the situation no I
think Anna actually has pretty good
chances here exactly she can improve her
position put the King on the optimal
Square pawns the rook and then go after
blocks separate pawns exactly we have
more Pond Islands how seriouses are
Anna's chances I want to ask Almira
um
much more now
plus one plus one and I managed to win
The crucial pound on C5 right and the
computer likes her position very much
she's just played King C3 by the way to
interrupt you sorry thank you three but
it doesn't change much because she will
try
um to activate her book let's say she
can play next Rook G6 and Rook G7 that
would be a dream come true so but if you
play Rook f8 here let's say
real Cafe maybe you can immediately play
Rook E6 and win the pawn on E5 and we do
have by the way A7 A5 as we were talking
um and I think that Anna is actually
right to play on because Jean Saya was
completely out of form there is the
during this tournament and she's I'm
pretty sure she's completely disgusted
with her position here she uh doesn't
think much she uh she plays almost
intuitively here so she she doesn't want
to defend this position that's actually
the the most yes the point actually yeah
and by the way the little by little but
I like this move very much these petite
moves Rook G6 improves the position why
does it improve the position a moment
ago we couldn't uh play the desirable
Rook H7 check but now Rook G7 is on tap
uh if you try to to um
to activate your Rook yeah you're just
giving me the A5 pawn and if you try to
activate your Rooker King
this is actually even worse so watch on
every move to not blunt or something
right and once again as we started our
show Mary said what ifs
if Anna wins today and Bella loses and
Irina doesn't win her game
and I won the tournament today one round
ahead guess what of those three things
all possible one two three all seem to
be happening not just possible but even
happening Rook G6 Bella's definitely
losing Irena has a draw and if Anna
converts this that's it that's it wow I
like this move Rook G6 a lot and
um I'm sure like you say the
cold-blooded engine finds ways of
Defending but if you just put your human
touch on it for a moment how does a
human even go about trying to defend
this position because I see lots of ways
for white to play for a win and it's not
so easy for black
to defend
maybe at some point you would have to
sacrifice a pound and exchange the
Knight against the bishop I mean The
Rook ending is uh your way to to get out
right and so maybe bishop F7 here let's
try Bishop F7 yes because I absolutely
yeah is that a pause for a moment there
because you're inviting Rook G7 of
course that's uh that's the idea but I'm
trying to uh to hold by King D6
94 chat let's say 94 check then I um
King D5 oh my gosh but I might have six
then King is six I see I see so
something like this you don't lose a
piece uh this way okay but it's not
always easy to make this move Bishop F7
but for example what else well that's
the problem I it's that what else the
what else actually has been answered
after Rook G6 the what else was Bishop
to D5
but now you can play Rook G7 with the
check and the computer gives already
plus two a bit more so because pretty
sure you cannot make this move King B6
let's say Knight D7 check then King A6
and maybe E4 well E5 is hanging for sure
so that's a a nice gobble
um but by the way but no black I'm sorry
I was thinking of B4 it's like these
Checkmate patterns right B4 a b king
takes B4
uh
how are we defending the checkmating
pattern
no but before you shouldn't think I
think you can play Rook H7
oh Rook A7
wow okay once again I would think that
this is winning Rook takes A7
you take on B4 I assume
because if you take on A7 I want to take
the pawn yes no I think King A7 and
because the these pawns are doubled
maybe you still have some chances to
draw the game but King is seven yes what
I I think it was just dead dead Amira
this the this configuration of the
Knight and the palm means you can't
touch me you know you you you'll have to
play King to D6 and by that time I'll go
around and around and I'll grab E5 uh
but Bishop D5 on the board uh clock
times again sorry uh Anna's down to two
minutes engine size has five and a half
minutes
five and a half to two minutes but they
only have two moves to make okay so
nothing nothing nothing but I think Anna
is looking at this position and telling
herself don't blow it don't blow it I've
got this I've got this and why doesn't
she have it
should I think she does have it practice
luck wow uh well she's on the verb if we
switch to Alexandra's game there was a
moment where
it looked like Bella was saving the game
again if she played King h8 she played
King f8 oh hold on hold on we left it
just here Rook F1 Queen E2 Bishop D3
Queen E1 I thought we were getting in a
G3 I think it was the G3 move that
killed it she didn't play it B7 Rook B8
Queen A2 King you're saying King f8 was
bad yes she had King h8 King h8
and What's the diff for example if I go
all the way down if you go Queen
Queen I have Queen f
9 and D1 Quinn okay and then I make a
girl or I take a rook sorry
and then you go back I go bishop d8 and
oh no and your only move is King G1 and
the Perpetual check that is crazy what A
variation but with King f8 that doesn't
work now you can because
the king would be here and I would have
Queen D6 check oh my goodness so King f8
terrible move and queen A8 and
she did it with two minutes on her clock
okay so Queen A8 what did Bella have in
mind
you probably thought either of those
moves were losing
so yeah
yeah and then now it's definitely oh
it's definitely a loss well Bella's loss
is Anna zatonsky's gain as
um one of the three things that she
needed to have happen happen
and now let's just turn our attention
quickly to Arena because I think we are
seeing what we were talking about the
shadowing of The Rook
no we didn't
no should I played Rook E1 so there's
sorry there's no they should be five
nebuchadne is trying to achieve more
than a draw so for example after Rook
here
I guess now I have to correct
okay accept it and after everything
actually there's Rook D3 Rook ah going
after the beat report thank you that
clears some cobwebs because yes this is
a much better way of Defending uh the B2
Pawn
then okay so Bishop C6 on the board
clocks one minute one minute one minute
four how many moves four more moves
well this is a key moment I I want to
say uh I still feel like it's very easy
to blunder the game away I mean very
easy right
let's look at Alexander's game she's
winning but it's just a funny position
because that we might see Four Queens on
the board
what this is crazy how did the okay we
left it here Queen
Queen 88 Queen take a rook with check
check check
uh and we've got Queen G1
that's our our key move so something
like King H5 which is on the board we
could make a queen
yeah how many times do you see Four
Queens on the board that's that's not a
common occurrence
no how fun it would be though if if we
could play
with four points
you know twice as much to calculate yeah
Victor coach now I made the observation
that uh two Queens on the board aren't
so powerful and his argument was is that
they control so many squares that they
double one another
so sometimes for example I have a queen
and two Rooks and I'm at the the two
Rooks are even better than the second
Queen right that the second Queen isn't
as powerful as the first queen
interesting perspective as
well there you have it Four Queens it is
the queens of chess tournament right I
mean it's only fitting it took us eight
rounds to have Four Queens on the board
but uh definitely Queens of Chess let's
just let's just take a picture right
here somebody do a screen capture
four inches going for those Checkmate
patterns that you were talking about
absolutely and they just reached the
move 40 so it's going to take King
before and then after Rook A7 King takes
B4 Rook A7
I wanted to say was Rook takes A7 and
I'm gonna push the pawn to A5 I can go
97 here oh sorry uh exactly
oh uh in Anna zutanski's game uh we're
anticipating Anna playing King takes B4
is where I see on the live view right
there we had but King takes before is on
the board and she's threatening mate in
one
and I saw that the table base
after Rook A7 a trade of Rooks because
again you you have to defend made so the
trade of Rooks and the pawn goes to
right I couldn't start with 97 and win
the pawn
because on e4 I have Knight F6 right and
I'm sitting there saying I have no
interest in the poem Oh I just I I wanna
I want the configuration where your king
is absolutely stuck
so I put the king here and then I'm
gonna play E4 and then you're gonna
bring the king over and win with the
King yes so and by the way I can play E4
maybe at the very start so Rook takes A7
King takes A7 E4 Drive the bishop I
don't care just away right and then I
get this uh is this is this a table base
uh or is it
unknown unknown okay it's not table
based but it sure looks to my eyes good
enough this looks like uh there's one
problem Please block has an idea once
your king is far enough I can go Bishop
G6 and Bishop takes E4 okay so uh you
wait if you feel essentially two for
some reason yeah so or yes as soon as
you go to G4 this is what I this is what
you're saying right I can take on e4
gotcha and then yeah you're you're
you're in time so I don't I don't win it
with the ABCs so it means that I don't
have to play E4 then I'll play here
uh wait
here wait and let me play it without E4
I want to bring my king
all the way around the board
yes I think you should keep your Pawn on
E2 or E3 and we have a resignation as
wow the streak has been stopped four in
a row yes no draws for Bella yeah she
had such a good opportunity today to
play Ruku G2 but
Alexandra defeated her and now good news
for Anna by the way we talked about the
roller coaster ride that Arena Crush has
been on I think uh Alexandra has been on
even a greater roller coaster ride
because she defeated humpy who withdrew
from the tournament due the illness
there went a point lots of decisive
games going on in the Alexandra's
tournament as well
so our congratulations to Alexandra and
Anna's delighted everything's going
it's going this way so far right irina's
not wait let's look at Arena's game we
have one pair of Rooks have been
exchanged
there is a missing
B2 Pawn on the board hold on who's
winning who's better and why just a
second uh so when we left it we did see
this move coming from afar Rook but we
thought Rook D3 was the right approach
time trouble making fools of us Rook
came
rookie one oh
Bishop E5 when I may have missed this I
think certainly a good name is uh the
move Bishop E5 that's on a B3 does a
great job at uh giving us a back rank
mate so she had to
uh and well Arena why isn't Arena
winning now how
take a pawn take upon on D6 yeah Bishop
Bishop D5 and I will be taking your Pawn
as well
well that's not fair just a second I I
was hoping it would be play on one goal
maybe uh you have A5
okay just so well I'm I'm so excited
that I won the pawn on B2 I think I I
got myself too excited there Rook C
no Rook C6 rookie five what am I
thinking that can't be right so I have
to play Bishop takes D6 right and you'll
Play Bishop to D5
um
darn it Bishop A3 is interesting
well Bishop A3 was the only but you A5
I'll get Rook a rook C5 but you do have
this move Rook F1 and that might be just
enough to draw the game it appears that
the players have made time control yes I
think everyone has time control okay
we'll we'll calm it down just a little
bit what about harika's game
earlier we didn't get a chance to talk
about
Pawn a great position I saw with the
engine during the break it was minus
four at some point minus four but now
she's trying to win The Rook ending with
an extra Pawn but I'm not sure it's
winning okay
so I think Erica has saved her game
ah King to D4 he'll be three against one
well I do have this massive thread of
track
and taking if I take the F5 Pawn I feel
like I am I'm okay uh somehow I'm okay
sorry you were about to say Nasi that
this might be drawn now yes uh harika
has played the end game really well
plugins to play F4 and then there's King
takes D5 exactly a great active rook and
suddenly counter counter play with the
this is definitely not what Nana needed
to do uh for counter play to allow the
counter play there with the pawn so
harika uh fighting her way back Ana
zatonski uh just your knee-jerk we've
been looking at this position with the
pawn on E2 we could also put the pawn on
E3 so it's on a dark Square in la de da
da but if I get the pawn to A5 you think
Anna's winning yes I think so just nice
I'm trying to think if there's some
setup where blood can defend that end in
right and what we're talking about of
course is Rook takes King takes this
exact position where we just get this
King kind of stuck this Knight and pawn
combination keeps Black's King in a box
yeah like it's kind of an invisible
sphere and when black is just moving the
king perpetually white moves the King
around
uh it could be something very special
for Anna bit Almera you're with the
guest in studio
uh thank you yes sir Alexandra is in the
studio with us welcome Alexandra
congratulations well your tournament is
very hard to watch for me especially
it's a it's a real roller coaster
unfortunately
well you're we will not analyze all the
games here but let's have a look at this
position uh your move Bishop B4 is quite
a rare move but I think by transposition
you can get to those positions probably
I didn't know that this line
uh would happen because there are so
many lines in the um this open rui Lopez
and she didn't have any games
so it just shows that there was a game
actually in Saint Louis between shankunt
and sibian I think was this bishop of
four king cage one and okay I thought
that it's relatively fresh idea of
course it should be about equal but
unfortunately I mean that's nowadays
Syria so
to your opponent surprised you but you
surprised her oh she didn't surprise
because I was expected I was expecting
the open rui Lopez but I didn't know
which line because there are several
pretty drawish lines and you're kind of
trying to
um come up with an idea and every single
one of them so this one was not
okay that was just one of the
possibilities and yeah so Queen theater
didn't look at home it would be small
and accuracy what did you expect in this
position well I don't know I didn't know
what to expect I knew that uh in this
game between Sean King I think coach
played there was another game with Queen
B6 which is also quite inaccurate
because of Bishop G5 and then F4 and G4
but Queen C8 I mean at least it guard
it's guarding the square G4 and even
though G4 is still possible uh after
Bishop E7 but I thought
your eyes are
I'm not in this kind of um like
right now my conditions are not the best
one to go for such complications
so I decided to play four by the way we
switched the computer off because we
decided to analyze this game because it
was very highly complicated from a human
perspective I wanted to know what
Alexandra
thinks here so after Queen City you took
Bishop Bishop B7 and you went for the
typical idea yes because she was playing
it's clear that she's going to play G4
and I decided to like prepare the
control play on the a file after that
and here it's at every moment there is
some kind of choice which is which makes
difficult for black to play okay seven
for example Rook D7 was possible and I
was like hesitating whether to take just
on D7 and take on T4 and okay it still
should be a draw but I'm kind of easier
to play for me
ah there was another possibility but
okay but did you take C3 yeah I was
thinking for a very long time I was
choosing between Community B1 and queen
F3 but I didn't see anything because the
idea is that after Rook G7 there's
Bishop F5 working
uh but of course Ruby G7 is a mistake
and I didn't see anything after Queen to
E6 Queen F3 Queen E6 and uh well then
depending on what I do see four and
Bishop C5 that's why I played Queen B1
and she surprised me with Bishop H4 I
didn't expect Bishop H4 after Queen B1
yes Bishop H4 I didn't calculate at all
because I was thinking only about Queen
E6 instead
and the idea is that if I take on a 5
she takes with the queen yes and I take
she takes I take I mean and then there
is Rook F4 and rookie a doesn't help
that's why after Rook D2 in this line
it's a draw so after Queen is six B
takes a sphere Rook G2 I was considering
H3 H3 preparing all these ideas was
Queen B5 rookie seven and Bishop F5 well
still should be a draw but Bishop H4
somehow it surprised me and then she
played before I don't know whether she
went for the spawn sacrifice or she
simply blundered because after she takes
before she takes before okay Queen takes
before is possible but I think even
stronger is Bishop B3 well at least I
was going to play Bishop B3 King th8
Rook C1
and then queen bee through C to C7 I
didn't see anything for black hair I
mean well it looks very convincing yeah
well back rank is very weak and it's
always scary but uh Rook G7 is coming so
she played C4 and I thought okay I have
an extra pawn my position should be good
and I spent a lot of time here and I I
went yeah B5 although I'm not sure
because there were other moves like
Quincy one Queen A1 I mean many moves
that I was considering just to protect
the square on the two even instead of B5
I liked at some point Rook D1 a lot but
then I Bishop of two she plays and
somehow I didn't
know what to do yeah I need to go away
but after Rook G2
I mean you feel that it should be
winning of course she has country play
Rook D1 C3 and I thought that I should
be winning and I have a lot of time and
I thought okay I will try to figure it
out but then after Queen C5 of course I
missed it completely
then this idea Queen F2 Queen E1
and well I decided to play it safe but
apparently I missed something right okay
but Queen A2 was another option that I
was considering and I liked a lot King
h8 through K8
yes so the same idea like trying to but
then Bishop GH plays
and I was calculating here like
something like even B7
um Queen F2 Rook G1
I mean just not to blunder anything you
know and I mean I liked it too
um I don't know what is evaluation I uh
and but no let's let it let us but okay
what I decided that Queen just Rook D7
is is safer but apparently yes here yes
here we at least I can tell you because
in this position we saw that after Rook
D7 uh black had this incredible uh
possibility to save the game or at least
to stay in the game after object too
because you cannot take it very
unfortunately I mean that would be very
unpleasant to see on the board of course
yes so but I shouldn't Miss such
possibilities for well what was in time
pressure here well she liked her plan
with Queenie one but I don't think it's
so dangerous because okay I I captured
City here I was somehow choosing I
couldn't couldn't choose what is
stronger Queen B3 King hh3
and play in this position
um well because she needs to retreat her
Bishop to E7 for example and then I play
B7 Rook B8 something like this yes yes
22 Queen G4 yes that was I was missing
and that's when I saw it I thought okay
no it's not it's not the way to go yeah
exactly because I was at first
considering it and that's why I played
Rook F1
I mean but in this position you're
always afraid to blunder or something
Queenie too because he always wonder
whether you have to include this check
or not on a21 B3 whether you need to
play B7 and you try to
um like evaluate all those
complications but okay I went and you
don't want to anymore I don't I mean
after yesterday's game when I just
completely you know
gave away a huge Advantage you always
feel like you you can do the same in the
next game so Rook B8 yes here but I
didn't see what she can do no no this is
completely winning uh okay it's scary
Four Queens on the board you're always
afraid of you know blundering something
but okay yeah it's quite safe
Queen G1
and well it was quite a thriller
Alexander thank you very much for for
all of us
Baltimore is the last round of the
tournament that's a good news and well
what are your feelings so far
well unfortunately I've given away too
many points I mean this tournament I
knew that okay two tournaments in a row
is quite physically demanding already
but I got I mean sick and I needed you
know to to play with this cult and it's
of course didn't help
and uh but again I think I'm playing
here uh better than I played in Cyprus
and the quality of the game of the games
sometimes very good of course this whole
situation was taking away my hope like
the whole point it didn't help I mean it
took away some energy not even physical
energy but emotional energy and it it
matters but again as long as I win at
least I mean even after losing but it's
already good but because in Nicosia for
example out of 11 rounds I won only one
and here it's been already quite a few
thank you Alexander
thank you and indeed our congratulations
we thought it was a thriller uh
definitely and uh well Alexandra's games
have been great I have enjoyed watching
uh very much uh breaking news however is
that uh Anna has played the movie E2 E3
and I must say let me say right away
that I don't see the problem with this
move but uh VAR is telling us no E3 was
not the right move
was to play 97 and take that pawn as
soon as possible do it right away that
we're looking at with Pawn on E3 and
Pawn on A5 and the King run engine says
it's it's a draw really yeah uh could
you okay well let's see why E3 King
A4 King A5 lets us make some moves for
black right you don't mind
and uh we'll just I'm going to I'm going
to bring the bishop back and forth uh
make a pretense that I know what I'm
doing and I don't and I'm just going to
bring my king all the way around right
so at a certain moment I'm going to
threaten to take this pawn and
we get to the position where the engine
still thinks it's even at this moment so
there's a way to hold this at some point
yes we have a kind of a bishop back and
forth by izan Saya so yes sorry excuse
me so instead of allowing you to go to a
two or five yeah I would play Bishop G6
in this position so okay
so we're gonna go here instead I'll go
King here location G6 I'll go King here
Bishop H7 and when you go King F6 I play
E4 okay
which is fine right
but you can't take that upon because I
have King A6 and the pawn and Dennis I
agree I'm not gonna sorry but I'm gonna
go here and I'm gonna take this part
okay King so let's say Bishop G6 to G6
you're standing and Bishop E8
wow you're telling me that this I can't
I can't even give you that pawn you can
give me this
okay how do you improve I already did my
dear I wanna I'm so proud of myself just
a second let me let me Pat myself on the
back
and you're telling me I can't win this
position
wow wow I'm I must find I must say I
find it a little stunning yes way to
progress from here is to win the E4 Pawn
but as soon as you win E4 you lose the
A5 Pawn right and then we know that's a
draw exactly so I so I can't get you in
a situation where let's say my night is
on C6 and your king is absolutely
absolutely stuck
and I can't chase your Bishop away from
this Pawn
wow okay that's that's deep that is
really
uh stunning for me because I I would
have thought that this would have been a
win you know I think long time ago if
this game was played before the engines
people with black pieces here would just
resign
or or adjourn and then find uh what's
going on uh
but so you're saying from the very start
it was important to play Knight D7 Shaq
and Knight takes E5 as soon as possible
because the question is actually already
on A7 yeah so the question was for
example we after Rook A7 if I was if it
had been in my mind that I need to win
the d-pawn at the E5 Pawn I might have
started with Rook D7 but I'm not
required to take here I can go let's say
Bishop G2
four
we're about to take
you're about to take
maybe you could play E4
if you want I don't know if you want to
play E4 or not here
yeah the making upon moving and end game
itself yeah yeah it's very very tough
but okay let me just refresh my board
because this current position I thought
Anna was cruising to Victory uh let me
do it okay so the we just seen Bishop A2
I assume we're going to see Bishop T5
now that I've kind of got a little bit
of an understanding
about the position
previously when I play E4 you're going
to sacrifice your Bishop at the right
time exactly and so uh the idea is that
you're going to put your Bishop on the
G6 diagonal so whenever I get close
to the pawn
uh
You're Gonna Play wants to go King F6
yeah I'll go E4 so once I so I have to
make a move
E4 wow
so this your your Bishop is trapped
it's funny if I could have played if I
could play
I don't know if it's better to have the
bishop in front of the Pawn on C2
instead of passive H7 I'm not sure okay
so you could have had that anytime you
want it by the way you could have had
your Bishop in front of the pawn
an E4 and E4
H7 is almost trapped yeah I know
Almera I mean you have studied your end
games uh like a good student your whole
life do you find this end game as
shocking as I do because I gotta tell
you I always thought that the dominant
King and Knight overwhelmed the the
passive Bishop
uh well I agree with you yes sir but
once again the computers they have
changed our prison the way we look at
the positions because we know that there
are so many defensive resources
available but I wanted to understand the
reason uh behind why E3 changes the
relation completely the computer says
that first of all after 97 and I missed
a win because it was a completely
winning position because you cannot play
if we're here because you don't can't
have the bishop on D5 here so you have
to have it on the
H7 G6 because after Knight F6 you win
the pound immediately so first of all
Anna missed a clear win in this position
so here after E3 I wanted to understand
what does it change if we play soon uh
let's say if we play Bishops
and 97 right as you can see the computer
hesitates but he goes for a very
interesting defense I didn't even think
about it so King A6
yes given the pound and now C5 okay this
is not going to happen of course this is
not going to happen but this will help
us understand what are the positions
that we are aiming for so let's say King
E5 here and then if you play Knight C4
then you will go King A4
foreign yes we need to understand this
position so E4 Bishop B1
then I'm going to stop you yes from
queening and I will play Bishop F5 so as
soon as your knight is moving I will
take the pawn on E3 so can we actually
win this one so let's say 93 Bishop to
where Bishop B6 yes I think I need to uh
to keep it here and King D6 so we're to
King Bishop G8
I do understand that this looks
incredibly dangerous but I think yes
that actually black can draw this there
is no way just for you to kick my Bishop
from this diagonal or to close on the
diagonal if the bishop would be here
let's say why we are keeping the bishop
on G8 let's say yes if I would go on a 2
then Knight D5 of course is winning
then Bishop GH is actually essential so
when I saw this this line this sequence
of move it moves at least now I can
understand why the computer evaluates
this position is well as drawish so but
of course uh the human perspective is
completely different so let's have a
look uh actually played E4 E4 this is
the position on the board yeah okay so
but now the computer changes the
evaluation completely but what happens
C5 that's on the board this is winning
the pawn again so yes so if you play
Bishop D5 here I think black isn't
suicide here maybe King A5
[Music]
okay so I think that uh well E4 is
a terrible mistake but can you protect
the pound from B1
once again how how will you progress
from this position if you're playing
King F5 then maybe bishop C2
so let's see if that is three King D4
King B3
King B6 King D4 King D4 but then if we
go for the same line we know that we
need to go for King A5 King A4 here that
I have Knight takes E4 and Knight C3 or
I don't know let's say Bishop C2 Knight
C3 you don't get your king to the
desired A4 Square
I don't know if like King B6 you have to
bring now your king closer but I agree
with you completely I think that's uh a
lot of players would have resigned with
black already
so uh don't say still defends in this
position and she played the probably the
only move Bishop B1 to stay in the game
wow and Anna goes for A4 okay let's
check
A4 so Bishop C2
if she goes for A5 right now let's say
we wait with the bishop and then King
comes over and then maybe the king king
C3 simply you don't have the square
anymore so you will have to play Bishop
A2 and Knight E4 and win in the game
we're back to uh a win well we played
the game of what ifs and BFS are all
coming to fruition for Anna zatonski as
she appears to be winning a very very
difficult and tricky ending Arena Crush
drawing very nice drawing Bella already
lost and Bella has already lost and just
to remind everyone if Anna wins this
whether Irina draws or not she will make
a Grandmaster Norm that's true
absolutely clinches the tournament
Victory as well exactly all right well
uh let's just take a short break as we
as the penultimate round uh comes to a
close by the way we did have a sorry to
harika's fans of course that we haven't
been picking up on her game as uh while
Nana's still upon up but we think closer
to a draw than a win for
um
uh in going on okay just by the way how
close is Anna to winning we just had a
five check
A5 check well let's just pause let's
pause our break for a moment A5 check
well we got to go back with the King
let's assume King back to A7 and we
we're coming to pick up the E4 Pawn Yeah
well hold on
tell me how I'm winning this King C3
it's like King A8
oh we have King B2 ideas maybe does that
work you're winning a king and con end
game ah
the split pawns
you're not in the Square yes oh the
bishop is actually trapped on the B1
Square maybe it was better to have it on
H7
we're discovering things about this
ending because uh we're it kind of role
reversal of the bishop being trapped on
instead of being trapped on H7 it got
trapped on B1 B1
so A5 check we're anticipating King A7
and now well in that case it means that
we can play King B3
if if we're gonna yeah if we're gonna
hunt down the bishop and trap it then we
can do it with King B3 and King B2 so
there's no escape with Bishop A2 even
the Escape I I agree I might might be
losing
it's a very good decision by Anna to not
repeat moves earlier that's what I'm
saying that's what I was saying I was
arguing our case and her case was uh I I
can't be losing this position and I can
maybe win but I I will say Josiah has
been playing really fast in this end
game it's hard to figure out how should
black hold the draw but she was just
playing intuitively and walked into this
lost end game now yeah I I think it had
a lot to do with the fact that she's
been unsuccessful in the tournament she
probably felt okay you know this almost
anything I can do draws and that was not
uh the case never the case never the
case so we're expecting King A7 King B3
and Kings 7 doesn't make any difference
because we can still play King B3 and
there's no King D6 simply because of A6
exactly and that's a that's a coronation
just to put that on the board there so
if we and King A7 is on the board by the
way but King C7 and if you thought well
I'll go and capture your knight I have
different I have new ideas and you're
not even in time to get to A8 anymore as
it's a girl so King A7 is on the board
and we're expecting this move King B3
ensnaring the bishop and the idea is the
threat of King B2 will induce Bishop D3
will take an E4 and Black's king is not
able and she's done it came to B3 to
stop the E6 bondage she sees the idea
because this one's quickly if she went
for the E4 Pawn that's still another 50
moves together right exactly that was
what I was thinking that we might be
here for another 50 moves but uh this is
not 50 moves this is a a past e-pawn
so King B3 on the board and regardless
of whether the king moves or the bishop
comes to D3 the threat is King B2
forcing the bishop to D3 take it just
snap it off and then win this King and
pawn end game with
the passers
whoo
what a game what an instructive end game
and once again I mean for Anna zatonski
a tournament victory
is clinched Grand Master Norm earned
earned earned forty five thousand
dollars
Cairns Cup champion that you can't take
that away that's that your name's
engraved on the trophy and I mean who
has done that one round before the
finish right
in such strong tournaments that almost
never happens exactly and I mean we were
thinking to finish tomorrow could well
have decided everything and Arena while
we know the history between these two
great Champions uh Anna and Arena trade
between them they have a dozen
championships exactly so yeah so it's
sort of like Anna said you know what let
me finish this today yeah let's make
tomorrow not that important a day and
what uh our congratulations what can we
say Fantastico
because I I think zhensaya is just now
fully aware that Bishop D3 Knight takes
D3 is an issue
yeah maybe she missed that and she also
thought that she was gonna give up E4
pawn and then maybe take the a pawn and
still draw use it as a decoy yes didn't
realize her Bishop was just trapped on
B1 wow
um not that it not that it matters at
least from the tournament perspective
but uh Arena as the better of the draw I
mean Rook takes G5 I mean it would
matter if I remember wins this yes then
she would just point behind Anna right
I thought a point and a half but I could
be wrong I thought Bella was the one
that was closer no no it would be Point
Bella was halfway so it could still be a
playoff if Irina wins today ah then she
would play for a win tomorrow gotcha but
let's look at the position I don't think
she's I don't think so either
yeah this is really uh it's 99 I think
so I think so too I do
but it's all about the Anna satonski
show
wow
wow this is that
and by the way this will be your first
win with the white pieces
she's been doing it with black well she
couldn't win the tournament without one
win with the white pieces exactly
exactly
I think she knows that it's she's got a
close daughter I wonder if she even
looked at other players results today or
they would stress her out too much right
she seemed fastened to her own uh uh
board uh What uh our predecessors called
good sits flesh
yeah however after she wins this then
she's gonna check and see that Bella
lost her game and irina's drawing hers
and
How Sweet It Is
words of Jackie Gleason
I can't even imagine how many rating
points Anna is gaining
you know what that's just you know cream
on the cake icing on the cake
and um
I mean probably one of the worst
tournaments of her career I was about to
say she hasn't won a game
which is really shocking because in this
tournament where you see you see so many
decisive games
you can't always just be the victim
right
so something uh definitely has gone
wrong for uh since I in this event same
to the same for arena as a opponent good
name right she actually did win the
first round we forgot about Bella's with
Bellas presents that she gave to good
night exactly that was the Knight G4 yes
early in the opening she plundered a
piece right but since then grenade
hasn't scored
oh very tough field yeah
and Anna taking a sip of victory
she is because I know she double triple
checks everything but she's so confident
that she's winning she got off the board
right and we're going to see The
Exchange now let's see it
only takes D3
what did you say about Double Entry
that's exactly what she's doing
probably even Kingston 3 is winning but
obviously not as fast as Knight takes D3
yeah I know I mean I I Wild Horses
aren't going to stop me from playing
Knight takes D3 and E4 uh for Anna and
by the way E4 is the only winning move
because if white spends one extra Tempo
playing King C3 then it's not a win
anymore really okay because King A6 and
Ken will be in this Square in the Square
the triangle
Knight takes D3 E4 honor
she is calculating the line she
calculated before for the last time
right
do you say to yourself come on you can
do it you can do it Knight takes D3 E4
[Laughter]
realize that how stressful it is when
you know you're winning your heart's
exploding right
what I'd be doing would be calming
myself down so I don't drop all the
pieces
yeah
she knows she wins this and it's over in
your eager excitement to play Knight
takes D3 there's such thing as too
excited right
Knight takes D3 and once again
we just have to follow it up with E4 E4
on the board yes uh because the point is
King C3 wasting a Tempo allows King A6
and King takes A5 but E4 should play it
immediately immediately
she's calculated all the lines now and
yeah
play a few more moves
in his book Grand Master preparation
left Polly guyowski talks about a an
adjournment he had with Ben Larson
and the adjournment required bent Larson
to play something like
14 incredibly sure
look at that smile oh
wow she almost ready to burst into tears
I think uh happiness as
E5 I I don't think she has realized yet
that the other games went her way as
well right and that she is a few moves
away from winning the championship
because irina's games going to be a draw
right
wow
wow just
wow oh congratulations
Anna what uh
he's amazing uh coming in as the last
seed by rating and having a tournament
performance outstanding plus four grand
master Norm with one round Despair and
probably gaining 30 rating points
I think I'm the king look at her wow wow
great Almera shared the moment uh as
Anna zatonski has just wowed us all yes
but it's like I've been silent the whole
time because I've been so touched by the
magnitude of this moment I am so happy
for Anna first of all she's a very close
friend but she told us that also how
difficult it was to to win such
tournaments and especially being a mom
and this is a miracle and a very
deserved Victory I think she
she's such a great player but sometimes
simply you will you don't play your best
and here everything was the lines the
Stars was aligned she played such a
great tournament she had her share of
luck of course but you need it because
um You Can't Win those tournaments or
by yourself sometimes so everything uh
well just went perfectly and we talked a
little bit this morning so I'm waiting
for her to come to our studio to share
her thoughts so well she shared that
um her sources of Inspirations were Pia
crumbling
and Monica but she is our hero right now
and she's the first American to win this
tournament she doesn't know it yet but
so she clinched her Grandmaster Norm so
this is a historical moment historic
moment wonderful and there we see
Arbiter Chris bird congratulating her
Arena's position because once again if
Arena were to win
then she would be tomorrow one point
behind exactly exactly and G4 checked on
the board
how is it so easily drawn
well if if Queen knows this end game
then it's easily drawn I
just stay
and King F6
and I'm just standing and when you push
the pawn on the white square I sacrifice
the bishop that I am going to okay so
let's say you wait yes you just uh you
just
I wait
for me and I have to actually end up
playing King to G5 if I want to play
um
Advance my pawns right
and now you go back yes yes and when you
try to come around again I give you a
check and make you go back
sorry Sid yeah what if the king tries to
come around Bishop C8
no no
I'm thinking F5 so that's why oh okay
sorry King F5 yes
I see exactly gotcha I think the easiest
choice to have the bishop on E2 right in
front of the pawns right so that way
black king can never leave G4 unattended
so we'll put our Bishop back right it's
taking J5 Bishop B5 F4 and Bishop B2 is
the easiest way to draw
and we'll just keep so anytime F3 comes
we sacrifice the bishop anytime your
king goes drifting too far away from the
G4 Pawn we snap it off King G2 and
Bishop E2 is uh the setup we want
current position let me just refresh my
board
this game because here players will
make a lot of moves before they agree
Twitter I think so too
verses one
I was about to say let's move King G4
looks like a really uh good move to
Simply cement if you go F3 I'll come
back put my Rook on F1 and grab this
Pawn
King seven and now white can just take
on G5
for sure allow F3 and then drop with
little K2 and my king is close enough to
come right back from the pawn exactly
and we spoke a lot about what the Grand
Master Norm is all about and here's a
graphic to explain it all
kids so it says if she wins she'll
receive her first grandma that's what
she wants and
yeah she's got the Grand Master Norm in
her hand because what she needs is a
plus three result yes she's already got
plus four so if she loses tomorrow it
doesn't matter She's Got The Grandmaster
but to get the Grand Master title she'll
need three norms and this is her first
Norm to uh
what did you call it title Supremacy
Supreme title pardon me uh Almera I've
heard it's hardest to get the first Norm
after that yeah yes exactly it's the
first million is easy
yeah
right and uh sorry I I kind of got lost
there uh it was looking at uh not on
this game King takes G4 Rook back King
back Rook back King back and we we we
just we we get back in time in front of
the pawn and we do pick it up so we do
think that herika will draw this game
after King takes G5
foreign
concerning thing in Arena's game is that
Rene is thinking because if she just
plays Bishop back drops her Bishop to uh
the E2 square or the D1 Square it's good
enough and just maintain and she's done
yes
certainly and Irina knew it I think that
far away look spoke for you know like I
know this is a draw and she's going to
find Bishop E3 and Bishop D1 and she did
and we're expecting a draw and that will
mean
that Anna will win the tournament yes
she she's clinched
first place there
our winners on her way to the interview
I just I just found that uh interesting
this idea that we played this game of
what ifs with ourselves but really it
was like the requirement of three things
happening and every single one happened
I mean it just it just worked out
perfect
chances of all those things happening
extremely yeah exactly I thought you
know we just mentioned it yeah for the
theoretical possibility that such a
thing could actually happen and it was a
requirement that this game be a draw
Anna was going to win and Bella had to
lose and two out of three and uh we're
about to see three out of three as we
get our uh tournament Victor miked up
for Wow Wow Victory interview wow
and we're ready Almera over to you
thank you yes sir Anna is in the studio
with us and congratulations thank you so
much for the victory we are so proud so
thank you so much I was like very like
nervous so today and I didn't expect
this openings and yeah at the beginning
probably would be happy withdraw but
okay uh let's uh go through the game and
just this night H3 already at least it's
a novelty okay the entire idea I didn't
see five right away and you only Bishop
B7 and Bishop A6 maybe I forgot
something there's such moves here five
yes I played Knight H3
yes yes so the idea is that if my knight
is still on F3 it's really like doing
nothing so idea maybe if she wouldn't
play H6 maybe like some ideas F3 or
yeah sometimes you can play F3 is three
yes and age six I'm not sure if it's the
right decision to take on F6 or not
well we analyzed it during the game it
was it was fine yes then I realized okay
why it should be like worse that uh like
uh your structure slightly slightly
worse my pieces okay I have weakness on
C4 and this risk we are potentially weak
here
19496 I was surprised that she played
very quickly I think here you have to
take your time and really realize what
kind of setup you want to get Yes
actually you're absolutely right because
now it's C6 is already a slightly
necklace yes wow well I can switch the
computer of course a little oh no it's a
six night H5
okay to sacrifice this was also I was
thinking about Rook did sacrifice and
well then it simply goes for some active
play
[Laughter]
I'm not sure if it's good or not but
you have six and I saw in some lines
this idea to play an H3 G4 but maybe
h3g4 it's like too slowly so I decided
to play like actively right away
this is not a G4 is it
is the first line or whatever no it's I
was thinking
as you can see
the same idea okay
so uh I think that your position was
very good okay here I don't know I don't
know why I've taken G4
I think G3 is probably dubious move why
uh she could play probably instead of G3
or beat the move I calculated during the
game and I was worried about later on
and and I I don't know if you realize it
yet but you about to well you won the
tournament wow the Drew that's it when
when I was living I was thinking here I
was not smiling I was thinking that if
it's dropped because like um feeling
like slightly misplaced and he she had
to find couple exact moves wow so you're
very happy unbelievable I cannot believe
that so this is probably your best
achievements yes in my chess career
definitely like the best in many years
and the best achievement actually I was
thinking that in any other sport you're
allowed to express your emotions but
when you won your game you know we saw a
small or a smile and then I was like I
just I just tired very tight yeah and
I'm still in the game so when are we
going to dance
play Chinese play table Chinese
everything yeah yeah thank you like El
Miro and thank you everyone especially
like all the generation who are
supported here me who gave me motivation
and uh trying to prove that age age is
just a number maybe not but I'm very
happy and before this event I was
mentioned in my role models and most of
them like older than me
okay so let's uh let's have a look at a
few critical moments here I wanted to
ask you because here you're clearly
better but actually I I I during the
game I I didn't know like for sure that
I'm better because then actually what
happened in the game that uh the
computer saw that
yes but I could not find the best
continuation what should I do maybe your
idea and
um to end what well then you can say
take you can take and it's maybe just
give up the spawn on Seafood no you
should be spiritually yes be just to
play this three yeah yeah I was thinking
about it I don't know wide and play it
actually even in the game uh that was a
very important Motif because if you
allow your opponents well if to take for
example let's say after
um
calculator I told you yes and then if
you take it I do not know what to do
here yes E3 but after E3 I didn't like
Rook g292 oh no no it's not here so it's
not here
anyway it was a very different important
defensive resource to have the Rook on
G4 and C4 yes yes so this is also some
rub it I don't know maybe I should take
on
Jacob sticks you've no not technology
six and play something here
with H4 which for that that's a little
bit not in a spirit of positions
yes but yes now yes
and I'm feeling that I'm missing
something during the game yeah
but anyway you were always yeah just
very awesome keeping the situation under
control I think it was always very
important so now and here Rook did of
course Rogue dieters was my first
temptation but after E5 Rook d8 yes
E5 a knife somewhere and
probably I'm still slightly better oh
but there's oh I'm at night oh 94 okay
yeah okay this I didn't see my
calculations yeah okay but let's get
back to the game because at some point
we were not sure if this ending was real
but this
okay
okay this is not winning but it's like
where I was very happy because nothing
too blunder I have a draw I have
perpetually I repeated this position
here I had about three minutes but in
such position you don't need much right
okay but after Rook H4 I think Bishop B3
was better right yes Bishop was better
so yeah but okay I need to try at least
I have Perpetual now right but uh tell
me here when you played Rook H4 uh well
did you have to convince yourself that
you have yeah yes okay I I wanted to I
would be very happy draw with a draw
because it was very tense game a lot of
complication but here I realized okay if
I'm not playing for win here what's like
no risk to lose at all I couldn't give
Perpetual check any time I want and
maybe
she's not having good tournament and
yes you're absolutely right and this is
so chance I didn't defend stumbling here
so she gave you I think I think like
here it was also instead of before
there's was it something better than
before or not uh maybe 97 also oh but
maybe yes I saw this but I uh after
before she is not obligated to take or
what well there was some unhuman
variations no no before before there is
another variation
what's the difference well then you're
okay this position come on this is not
serious yeah
so yes and then we came to this Saturday
and here was the end game yeah no no
sorry yes that's the game no but okay
it's serious look at the move actually I
calculated also 1997 and E4 no no no no
no no no no no no no one with Rooks on
the board but actually here did you
calculate Knight D7 yes of course 1974
and Knight of six Knights of six uh you
win the pound immediately
yes maybe but what's wrong with Israel I
think history is such a nice move I
don't know yeah nice and yes Sirens
analyzed your yeah maybe okay uh could
she move for Bishop on diagonal but I
think after
um she cannot explain Bishop Jade
because Knight
to D7 and F6 it's not actually weak like
this so
yes yes this is not so clear wow
[Laughter]
yeah this I know even if computer says
it's draw it's probably not so easy of
course but that's like after a three
hour hard stop beating because we were
thinking that the position is completely
winning but then uh no I didn't I didn't
think it was winning yeah I thought it
was much better with great chances and I
will play this game like
another is actually such a 50 moves yes
but now there is a clear past Victory
after E4 and you demonstrated yes yes
and I saw this in the game of course
yeah was very happy to and calculated
three times like
come back
next year
right I will do commentary and you will
pray
you have a deal yes it will also play
huge congratulations Anna one question
do you know that you also made the Grand
Master Norm uh okay I'm users are like
Amir already told me yesterday but are
you sure because as far by old rules I
know there is no GM Norm in eight rounds
it must be only a world team
championship or european Club cup but
only because of the players withdrawal
ah these are oh this is very nice yeah
yes
um
wow very happy I already mentioned who
became a GM around age of 40. so she's
like one of my role models and I want to
say hello to her and to thank you
everyone who was rooting for me I want
to thank you Olga sagalchik I visit here
in New York it was such a wonderful
atmosphere as well and Rosa galitiani
all my all the
childhood friends with whom I played 20
years ago
first year's championship your poor
husband
why
I think like in this tournament he is
not poor
well this was okay I I already thank you
many times
well it's never enough to say I love you
uh anyway this was an absolutely
outstanding performance and
congratulations thank you
our congratulations to be sure as Anna
zatonski is our 2023 Karen's Cup
champion with one around despair yes the
tournament will go on tomorrow it feels
like it's over but it's not it's not
over until it's over and Anna's taking a
handsome price one absolutely forty five
thousand dollars there's a Victor smile
if there was ever one as Anna zatonski
takes clear first Soul first
inspirational really the way she played
this tournament truly
truly
and the other two games that were still
running finished in a draw that's all
the games are over and this is our
standings after round eight
Messiah will get the buy tomorrow she
has completed her tournament she's
played all eight games again
it was going to be a 10 player round
robin became a nine player Ron Robin
when uh whom he were Drew and Anna
zatosuke wins the tournament with five
and a half points out of seven she still
will be playing tomorrow but no one can
catch her exactly and she will play
playing Arena who will be playing for
second prize of course
happy happy
and here are our pairings for the ninth
and Final Round uh tomorrow as the Astro
said bye round for Jean Sayer and Irina
crash will be playing Anna satonski Nana
that means that will be playing
against Rona Valley and pets against
Costa new as you can see a big big big
fight for second uh prize again a very
generous price fun so those players who
are fighting for second and third are
certainly going to be prepped and and
one more thing we will not have tie
breaks so tournament will end tomorrow
no tie breaks at all for this event uh
final thoughts on this penultimate
around in the crowning of a champion
Almira oh yes I'm still trying to gather
my own so it's because uh this is an
absolutely stunning Victory one round to
spare another zatonskick is our champion
and well I'm looking forward to more GM
Norms so this is going to be an enormous
source of inspiration for me and for all
the chess players around the world but
The Show Must Go On so we still have
another round tomorrow and I'm looking
forward to
um well to see who is going to be on the
podium
so are we so are we wow it felt great it
felt great it was a really really
wonderful day thank you all for joining
us and sharing your day with us for this
penultimate round where we crowned a
champion and we'll see you all tomorrow
see you tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited